[Musique]
Marc devel, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Serview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? Euh donc
euh je suis journaliste depuis bientôt
16 ans je crois me souvenir. J'ai 38
ans. J'ai travaillé pour différents
journaux de presse écrite principalement
notamment 5 ans à Marianne où je
m'occupais à la fois de la politique et
de l'investigation.
Et puis j'ai travaillé pour témoignage
chrétien, un hebdomadaire petit
hebdomadaire mais illustre hebdomadaire.
Et j'ai travaillé après pour le monde
diplomatique, pour capital pour
pour les incroybles, pour têtu pour
magazine TTU.
Voilà, j'ai travaillé sur des sujets de
société, j'ai fait des enquêtes
économiques, des enquêtes politiques,
j'ai également fait des affaires
politico-financières, enfin suivi des
affaires politiquo-financières comme par
exemple le dossier Big Malon. Euh voilà,
donc on va pouvoir peut-être en
discuter. Euh j'ai travaillé aussi sur
le dossier Areva euh
al notamment la deuxième affaire à Areva
qui s'appelle l'uranium gate parce qu'en
fait le montage financier, je l'avais
entre guillemets dévoilé en en juillet
2015 et puis voilà. Enfin après il y a
plein de sujets sur lequel je travaille.
Donc ce soir, on va se régaler. On est
au mois de décembre, c'est bientôt les
fêtes, donc on va faire une interview un
peu festive. Et euh on vous a fait venir
parce que vous avez fait plusieurs
bouquins qui nous ont intéressés. Euh
d'une part sur les réseaux Macron et
deux sur France Télévision, sur la
chaîne étatique sous influence. Donc on
va parler de tout ça. On va parler des
réseaux Macron, des réseaux cachés. On
va parler de la déontologie
journalistique, on va parler des
journalistes, on va parler de la presse,
on va faire tout le tour. Euh la
première question que je voudrais vous
poser, c'est qu'est-ce que vous pensez
de l'idée de Cédric Ha de créer un
conseil supérieur du journalisme ?
Ah oui, euh la fameuse sortie qu'il a eu
en en juin dernier
rapidement abandonné. Euh oui, parce que
ça s'apparentait quasiment, on va dire,
un conseil de l'ordre. Euh en plus,
c'était la parole pour le coup du
gouvernement.
Euh je sais qu' les différentes sociétés
de journalistes ont là sur euh la
création d'un observatoire de la
déontologie à enfin plus que d'un
conseil de la déontologie
journalistique, c'est opposé à dire
l'instrumentalisation politique de cette
histoire-elà. Moi, sur le fond, j'ai
rien contre au contraire que les
citoyens s'emparent de l'objet
médiatique, euh contestent le travail
des journalistes, c'est normal. Euh
mais euh concernant les rapports de la
Macronie, on on va avoir le temps d'en
parler et au travail des journalistes en
général ou des journalistes en
particulier qui travaillent sur euh leur
domaine, sur le gouvernement, sur le
pouvoir, sur l'État. Euh depuis
l'arrivée de d'Emmanuel Macron au
pouvoir à l'Élysée, euh on peut dire que
les choses se passent difficilement. Euh
et là, j'emploie un terme faible. Euh il
est supporter d'Emmanuel Macron. Là je
parle pas des fans hein ou des
militants, je parle des gens qui sont
dans son entourage. Euh en fait ont pris
les mêmes plis euh que lui vis-à-vis des
de la presse en général ou des
journalistes, c'est qu'il ne supporte
pas la moindre contradiction. Euh
c'est-à-dire que ils seraient eux
détenteurs de la vérité. Et euh après,
il y a tout le discours très très ambigu
sur les fake news. Et donc dans ce cadre
là, c'est assez compliqué de travailler
et et de faire de l'enquête. Mais il y a
aussi d'autres raisons. Il y a pas
uniquement le fait que Emmanuel Macron a
cette défiance et cette difficulté à se
voir contesté. Il y a également le fait
que comme aujourd'hui les partis
institutionnels
ont été écrasés par En marche et on va
dire la Macronie, il y a une sorte de de
système de parti unique qui s'est qui
s'est mise en place et ça a des
conséquences euh sur le champ
médiatique. Voilà, on pourra en parler.
Les conséquences euh alors c'est une
question que je m'apprêtais à vous poser
mais après 1hure et3 mais bon c'est pas
grave. Euh est-ce que c'est je vais je
vais prendre un mot très sale qui n'est
même pas sale cette caste médiatique ?
Est-ce qu'elle anticipe une réélection
de Macron et et est-ce qu'elle continue
de s'autocensurer parce qu'elle anticipe
une réélection de Macron ? Donc elle a
peur de se faire un petit peu taper sur
les doigts juste après sa réélection.
Alors il y a il y a deux effets de
neutralisation enfin il y a trois effets
de neutralisation principal aujourd'hui
de de des médias en France. Alors, quand
on dit des médias, on globalise. Donc
c'est c'est une c'est une formule un peu
rapide. Euh bien évidemment qu' a de la
diversité. Il y a il y a des gens qui
continuent de travailler ou qu'en tout
cas qui essayent de continuer de
travailler notamment, on peut le voir y
compris la à travers les manifestations,
les les journalistes qui couvrent les
manifestations parfois avec des
difficultés face au aux forces de police
comme Gaspar Ganzer.
Comme Gaspar Ger, il y a des
journalistes qui continuent d'enquêter.
Bon, on cite souvent Médiap, mais il y a
il y a d'autres organes de presse qui
continuent d'enquêter.
Reflet. Euh mais c'est vrai que euh
pour reprendre la terminologie que là
vous avez employé, c'estàdire la CAST,
euh c'est vrai que une bonne partie des
patrons de presse, alors managers de
presse, hein, c'est-à-dire euh les
directeurs de la rédaction, euh les
propriétaires de médias dans un second
temps, mais également ce que certaines
personnes appellent les éditocrates, en
tout cas les éditorialistes habitués des
plateaux de télévision bien évidemment
qui sont dans cette anticipation. Là,
c'est pour ça que je parle de syndrome
du Parti unique parce que bien
évidemment il y a d'autres forces de
position. On peut penser à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon à gauche et à l'extrême droite
Marine Le Pen, mais c'est des partis qui
sont peu en contact avec l'État et
également qui donc qui ont peu
d'expertise, qui ont peu de contact sur
les dossiers de fonds en fait. Euh et
donc ils ont ils ont eux-mêmes peu
d'information parce qu'il y a deux
aspects de neutralisation.
C'est dans l'autocensure. Il y a bien
évidemment il y a la il y a on va dire
en gros les gens pensent à leur carrière
avant tout et donc c'est vrai que le
fait qu'il n'y ait pas plusieurs chevaux
en course sur le plan politique
amène à à une très grande prudence d'une
partie des rédactions.
Euh et puis euh
bon, on pourra peut-être revenir sur mon
cas personnel, mais
donc je suis parti de Marianne pour
d'autres raisons, mais les expliquer
maintenant je suis parti de Marianne
parce que il y avait notamment un nouvel
investisseur, enfin nouvel actionnaire
principal qui a qui a racheté le journal
qui s'appelle Daniel Kretinski qui est
un oligarque tchèque qui investit dans
le domaine de l'énergie Et je me suis
aperçu que le réseau de Daniel Ktinski
notamment en France était à la fois lié
à des vieux réseaux de la droite
française en
France-Afrique Armement
genre oui genre de la SarkoZie genre la
case des dépôts.
domaine de l'énergie qui est un domaine
régalien comme on peut penser au
nucléaires bien évidemment, mais les
pipelines également, c'est c'est des
domaines géopolitique avec des enjeux
politiques de géopolitique, des enjeux
financiers extrêmement importants où
effectivement les domaines, on va dire
du complexe militaire industriel, les
réseaux du complexe militaire industriel
notamment commerciaux peuvent se
recouper avec ceux de l'énergie. Et donc
j'avais pas de défiance sur l'homme
Daniel Kretinski. Je voyais simplement
qu'il avait des activités notamment dans
les centrales à charbon, dans un
pipeline euh de gaz hein entre la Russie
et et l'Europe passant par l'Ukraine. Ça
c'est important. On reviendra peut-être
après. Et c'est vrai que par ailleurs,
il y avait différentes personnes dans
son entourage, y compris en France qui
là pour le coup été était en contact
avec des des réseaux, on va dire
totalement de l'ombre de la 5e
République, si j'emploie ce terme-là. Et
c'était et c'était difficile c'était
difficile pour moi de continuer d'avoir
une activité d'enquête indépendante et
autonome dans ce cadre là, hein.
Est-ce que Est-ce que les gens de chez
le monde quand ils ont ils ont vu Niel
débarquer, ils auraient dû faire la même
chose ?
Question piège, c'est une question.
Alors, je vais pas répondre sur le monde
déjà parce que on attendez, le monde le
monde c'est d'abord une institution.
Donc la la situation particulière de
Marianne, c'était que c'est une petite
rédaction. Euh c'était un journal
indépendant qui maintenant se retrouve
dans un groupe hein parce que Daniel
Kretinski a racheté d'autres titres de
presse euh notamment elle des titres
venants du groupe la garderaire des
titres people aussi enfin donc il en
fait un groupe de presse. Marianne pour
l'instant est pas totalement intégré au
groupe de presse mais il est quand même
le magazine est quand même intégré au
groupe de presse. Et par rapport à votre
question sur le monde,
eux sont dans une situation différente
parce que c'est 400 journalistes, ça
reste une institution donc les rapports
à leur actionnariat est quand même un
petit peu plus différencié. C'est il y a
moins de il y a plus de tampon, on va
dire. Euh mais surtout là en revenant
sur sur Kretinski, euh les réseaux sont
vraiment des réseaux au-delà des réseaux
économiques traditionnels. Et donc c'est
euh moi qui enquête ou qui a pu enquêter
sur justement des réseaux de la
France-Afrique, des réseaux du complexe
militaire industriel. Là pour le coup,
ça percutait totalement
mes domaines d'enquête.
On est loin du marché des Télécom.
Voilà. Et donc euh bien évidemment que
euh quand des grands patrons des télécom
investissent dans des médias, l'un des
principaux effets, c'est la
neutralisation euh de des enquêtes de
certaines enquêtes sur le domaine des
télécom.
Vous avez senti chez Marienne qu'on
allait vous neutraliser ou pas du tout ?
Ils m'ont pas retenu quand je suis
parti. Voilà.
Vous attendiez à être retenu ? Bon,
spécialement, mais ils m'ont partenu.
Mais après, quand on dit Marian, là je
parle de la la des nouveaux actionnaires
et de leurs représentants quand quand
ils sont arrivés dans la place. On on va
peut-être revenir euh dessus mais euh
euh pour revenir sur la la question de
neutralisation, on parle beaucoup de de
des grands propriétaires de presse.
C'est vrai que maintenant 90 % des
journaux sont mains de de très très
grosses fortunes, hein. Notamment
Bernard Arnaud, on a parlé de Aviniel.
Vincent Bloré également qui est en plus
extrêmement interventionniste, Patrick
Dra bien évidemment d'asso
euh d'Ass Figaro. Donc on est quand même
dans une démocratie un peu particulière
parce que 90 % de la presse et des
médias télévisuels, audiovisuel sont aux
mains de grands euh de grands très
grands propriétaires qui ont d'autres
activités et parfois ces activités-là,
on peut parler d'assaut, euh sont en
lien total avec euh avec euh l'État. que
ça soit par rapport à l'aspect
réglementaire de l'État ou par rapport
aux achats euh aux achats que l'État
peut avoir dans les différents secteurs.
Donc ça a des conséquences extrêmement
importantes.
Euh mais
c'est la nuance que j'y mets parce
qu'elle est extrêmement importante. De
mon point de vue,
le comment dire le l'explication
économique ou de la propriété des médias
ne suffit pas en elle-même à expliquer
l'affadissement du système médiatique,
la la perte parfois de pumnacité de
certaines rédactions ou euh ou des
éditoriaux
néolibéraux ou droitiers ou contre
certaines revendications sociales par
exemple. Euh là ça concerne à la fois
euh l'origine sociale des journalistes,
euh leur recrutement, euh également la
tradition journalistique française de
qui n'est pas celui de l'enquête ou du
reportage par rapport à d'autres pays
euh euh notamment anglo-saxon mais pas
que. Et c'est vrai que là euh il y a
d'autres facteurs qui entrent en ligne
de compte euh et donc que j'ai déjà un
peu exposé mais qui en plus euh
permettent aussi d'expliquer la
neutralisation actuelle. en tout cas une
certaine neutralisation actuelle des
médias. C'est-à-dire c'est pas quand
j'entends dire
c'est tous les oligarques qui
soutiennent Macron. En fait, les choses
sont plus compliquées. Déjà,
on va on va rentrer. On va on va rentrer
déjà parce que juste pour une petite
précision, déjà parce que ces oligarques
là peuvent être en compétition entre eux
industriellement parlant. D'abord parce
que leurs propres intérêts sont d'abord
leurs intérêts industriels avant d'être
revenir sur les intérêts de de BUIG sur
la 5G.
Voilà. Tout à fait. Et puis voilà. Et
euh donc autre question pour faire la
transition et puis après pour
c'était un peu
Non mais c'est c'est toujours comme ça.
C'est toujours comme ça ici. Bienvenue
sur S.
Donc le là on va embrayer on va embrayer
sur une question qui va nous faire
basculer ensuite sur la Macronie.
Comment vous expliquez cette défiance du
public envers ses journalistes, envers
sa presse ? C'est parce que il y a eu un
affadissement, parce que c'est des
passes plat, parce que ils font pas leur
boulot, parce qu'ils sont dans leur
petitte à se faire des petits vernissage
à Paris, parce qu'ils sont déconnectés
de la population, parce qu'ils ont peur,
parce que quoi ? Comment vous expliquez
que RT soit la chaîne encensée par les
gilets jaunes ? parce que ils ont
couvert les gilets jaunes avant tout le
monde dans des proportions correctes
avec des gens sur le terrain ? Ils sont
ils sont fait gomme cogner ainsi de
suite. Comment vous expliquez que les
autres organes de presse en
manifestation, ils sont obligés de
cacher les bonettes des micros ? Comment
vous expliquez ça ? Cette défiance,
c'est c'est même une haine.
Oui. Euh bah qui est problématique aussi
parfois quand les journalistes vent
travailler, mais je vais pas être dans
un discours corporatif déjà parce que je
le suis pas particulièrement. Euh bah,
elle s'explique pour des raisons
structurelles, hein. C'est-à-dire que
bon euh on on parle beaucoup de la crise
de la presse euh et notamment du fait
qu'elle serait euh enfin la conséquence
de l'évolution de la consommation sur
internet ou des choses comme ça. C'est
toujours en France, c'est toujours de la
faute d'Internet. Euh c'est jamais de la
faute des structures euh préexistantes.
En fait, notre presse euh historiquement
est extrêmement fragile. Euh
c'est-à-dire qu'après la Seconde Guerre
mondiale euh elle était en
sous-capitalisation en réalité quand les
journaux se sont re fondés ou recréés
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale et que
donc on paye cette sous-capitalisation
depuis 70 ans. Ce qui explique que les
journalistes se sont fait petit à petit
se sont laissés aussi hein, il y a eu
une passivité de la part des
journalistes. Ils se sont laissés, on va
dire leur rédaction hein,
ils se sont laissés mettre en laiss.
Oui, c'est ça. Enfin, des possédés
dépossédés de leur pouvoir dans la
plupart de leur rédaction vis-à-vis de
d'actionnaires que depuis 20 ans, les
actionnaires sont pas des actionnaires
de presse ayant des activités
principalement de presse en Allemagne
par exemple ou en Angleterre. Ça a aussi
d'autres conséquences mais le groupe
Murdoc par exemple en Angleterre ou en
Allemagne, le groupe Bertalsman par
exemple sont des sont d'abord des
empires de presse,
le groupe Springer aussi ou
euh oui je crois. Alors après il faut
j'ai pas la en tête tout toutes leurs
activités mais effectivement enfin le
groupe c'est Springer a eu des
investissements récemment américains
d'ailleurs mais mais
tu connaissez Mathias Doffner ? Enfin
oui, enfin je vois qui c'est mais je le
connais pas personnellement. Mais le ce
que je veux dire c'est que il y a eu une
accélération effectivement euh de la
dépossession des rédactions par la des
propriétaires de presse. Ça c'est
incontestable. Mais la fragilité de la
presse française, elle est liée
également à un système de distribution
extrêmement euh faible en réalité parce
que contrairement à ce qu'on dit dans la
presse, on n'est pas dans une économie
de l'offre. C'est paradoxal, hein. Euh
c'est-à-dire que les journaux comme les
livres d'ailleurs euh sont achetés parce
que ils sont disponibles à des points de
vente. Et le problème c'est que quand
depuis 15 ans, il y a près de 800 points
de vente de presse qui disparaissent de
toute la France euh et bien ça explique
en grande partie l'écroulement
industriel de la presse française euh en
plus de la question des contenus qui est
aussi à prendre en compte. Donc tout ça
est euh avec euh encore une fois plus
plusieurs explications sur le plan des
contenus. Euh il y a d'autres gens hein,
mieux que moi qui l'ont raconté, c'est
euh le fait que la la cette profession
qui était une profession ouverte à à
différents profils euh est devenue une
profession euh on va dire fagocitée par
les écoles de journalisme. Euh moi je
j'ai pas fait d'école de journalisme par
exemple. Euh donc ça ça crée des très
très bons techniciens de la formation
hein qui sont polyvalents entre la télé,
la radio, euh la presse écrite, mais
c'est pas forcément des gens qui euh
apprennent à enquêter, euh apprennent à
avoir un carnet d'adresse, à gérer des
sources, à comprendre les enjeux
politiques et économiques de leur
secteur, à comprendre les rapports de
force,
à comprendre aussi parfois qu'ils sont
instrumentalisés. Euh et donc il y a un
manque de réflexivité dans la
profession. Euh c'est-à-dire que les
journalistes, c'est c'est une expression
un peu c'est une la palissade, mais on
dit sciences son conscience n'est que
urine de l'âme. Bon, c'est prodophilo de
terminal. Mais mais ce que je veux dire,
c'est que il y a quand même peu de
retour des journalistes sur leur propre
travail. Euh et alors on va parler de
déontologie, on va sortir les grands
mots, mais euh ce n'est pas ça le fond
le fond du problème en réalité. Et donc
pour revenir à la défiance, il y a pour
moi deux principales raisons. C'estd que
on dit certains spécialistes de médias
disent il y a une surinformation. Non,
il y a un surbruit médiatique. Oui, il y
a une surcommunication aujourd'hui.
C'est-à-dire que il faut savoir qu'en 20
30 ans sur la place de Paris euh il y a
eu
plans sociaux sur plans sociaux parmi
les rédactions. Les rédactions quasiment
plus de moyens. les services
économiques, les services sociaux dans
les rédactions ont disparu euh ou réduit
à la portion congrue. Euh donc il y a de
moins en moins de de suivi des dossiers
quand c'est du rubricage, de moins en
moins d'enquêtes euh de long terme
également. Donc il y a des exceptions.
On cite souvent Elise Lu à la télévision
ou encore une fois Media Part ou le
Canard enchaîné. Mais euh ces
exceptions, le problème c'est que autour
euh le reste des médias bien par euh des
questions notamment de moyens également
de recrutement, de renouvellement
générationnel fait que euh ça explique
une bonne partie de la défiance. Et
après sur le plan politique, pour
revenir à à la question sur les gilets
jaunes, on revient à l'aspect
neutralisation que j'expliquais au début
sur c'est la règne du parti unique.
C'est-à-dire que la presse,
elle devrait devrait être ou en tout cas
certains le pensent, d'autres non, mais
elle devrait être un contrepouvoir un
contrepouvoir par rapport aux
institutions du pays, par rapport au
pouvoir économique, par rapport et la
presse donc devrait être un
contrepouvoir et donc plutôt un
porte-parole inversé de la population et
des de l'intérêt général si on est dans
les grands concepts.
En France, la presse a plutôt était été
la le relais des pouvoirs, le passep
et le passe plat, mais pour des raisons
aussi du fait que on était dans le débat
politique presque. C'est la la dite
presse d'opinion au 19e siècle. On s'est
Jean-Michel Apatti, c'est votre copain ?
Non, j'ai fait un portrait de lui
enquêté. J'ai fait une enquête sur
Jean-Michel Apatti euh ça lui a pas
beaucoup plu dans une revue, une petite
revue qui s'appelle Charles, spécialisé
en politique qui est dirigé par Arnaud
Vivian, un ancien journaliste de
libération. Et j'ai expliqué que
Jean-Michel Apati avait avait avait
débuté sa carrière dans un petit journal
que peut-être que certains internautes
connaissent qui est le journal Politis
qui été créé en 88 dans dans le giron du
PSU et des écolos. Et donc effectivement
Jean-Michel Apati a commencé par la
presse que lui-même qualifierait
aujourd'hui d'extrême gauche alors que
politi
très sympathique mais de gauche on va
dire. Et euh et donc pour revenir à la
l'aspect neutralisation, parce qu'il y a
aussi une neutralisation politique quand
même par rapport aux gilets jaunes,
comme les gilets jaunes euh
se sont exprimés hors du cadre
institutionnel, hors syndicat, hors
parti politique,
c'est ce n'est pas très étonnant que la
presse ait eu du coup de mal à suivre le
mouvement, voir à le couvrir tout
simplement. Euh
c'est grave de dire ça, c'estàd qu'ils
sont pas connectés avec le réel,
mais ils sont pas connectés par le réel
parce que pour plein de raisons comme
parce que il y a la tradition française
qui de toute manière et ça je vais
prendre un autre exemple, deux autres
exemples. Euh il y a eu euh il y a
quelques jours euh enfin quelques jours
quelques semaines la fameux le fameux
incendie de lubrisol
à Rouan. Bon euh la presse faisait quoi
? La presse couvrait la mort de Jacques
Chirac.
Bon, pendant les habitants de Ran
où il y a pas mal de gilets jaunes
d'ailleurs dans dans ce bassin d'emploi
les les voilà les les gilets jaunes oui
la population de Rouan pendant des
heures et des heures et des heures n'ont
pas eu de réponse à leur inquiétude
légitime sur la situation sanitaire par
rapport à la catastrophe.
On a beaucoup parlé de la des
défaillances au niveau de l'État du
gouvernement mais il y a eu aussi des
défaillances au niveau médiatique.
Pourquoi ? parce que en fait là pas de
correspondance sur place pour la
plupart. La presse locale a fait son
boulot, France Bleue a fait son boulot,
Paris-Normandie a fait son boulot. Donc
la presse locale mais la presse locale a
aussi des budgets en diminution. Donc il
y a de moins en moins de de
correspondants locaux, de moins en moins
de territoires couverts et en plus ils
sont en situation de monopole ces
journaux de la presse régionale. Et pour
revenir sur la sur le Brisol, donc il y
a là on est totalement dans une
situation de sous-information.
totalement en réalité. Euh alors, je
pense à l'UBisol, je pense par exemple
sur la question de de l'évaluation
du nombre de manifestants. Euh on donne
ça à un cabinet dit indépendant
où on donne les chiffres des syndicats
et de la police dans le meilleur des
cas. Euh mais on n' pas suffisamment de
journalistes pour couvrir une
manifestation, y compris pour donner euh
sa propre expertise. Euh un média
devrait avoir la la puissance, notamment
quand on s'appelle par exemple AFP euh
donnerait euh doit devrait pouvoir
donner son expertise sur euh la la
l'événement en cours de mon point de
vue. Et au-delà de l'ubrisol et de de la
manifestation, j'avais un autre exemple
mais j'ai oublié, j'ai un de mémoire.
Effectivement pour revenir à la à la à
la question de de la non représentation
là pour le coup, on va dire ou de la de
la déconnexion,
c'est qu'il y a quand même une voilà,
j'ai retrouvé mon idée, je vais un peu
vite, je vais me calmer. Il y a une
survalorisation des sources officielles
dans la presse française.
Et ça, on l'a vu dans un épisode
d'ailleurs qui a eu une importance enfin
ça a été un accident industriel de
presse de mon point de vue.
Ça a été sur le
l'affaire de fait, c'est un fait d'hiver
mais l'arrestation enfin la fausse
arrestation, la non arrestation de Dupon
de Ligoness
en Angleterre ou en Écosse ? En Écosse.
Vous
connaissez la Vous connaissez la blague
?
Non, je la connais pas.
Ah bah la blague c'est comme on peut
croire à un flic écossais alors que ça
fait 500 ans qu'il court après un
dinosaure dans un lac.
Bon mais effectivement cet épisode là de
de du pont ligoness donc on a tout de
suite dit que tout ça était une
défaillance venue informationnelle venue
des polices
peut-être mais à un moment donné les
médias doivent ce qu'on appelle
normalement c'est la base du métier
c'est recouper et recouper une
information c'est pas poser la même
question à à quatre interlocuteurs de la
même institution ou qui sont eux-mêmes
en train de s'autointoxiquer. Ça
s'appelle pas un recoupement. Un
recoupement, c'est recouper une
information à partir de sources
extrêmement différenciées qui ont des
positions extrêmement différenciées qui
justement ne sont pas censé pouvoir
s'auto-intoxiquer parce que sinon et ça
c'est la on pourra revenir dans la suite
de l'entretien mais c'est le c'est un
des principes de base d'une enquête en
réalité parce que même moi je peux me
faire intoxiquer parfois mais je
réfléchis, je rebarde, je vérifie.
justement vérifier, c'est pouvoir
recouper une information à partir de
sources différenciées. Et là, le
problème c'est que euh et je l'entends
et je le vois sur d'autres enquêtes que
j'ai pu faire d'ailleurs, hein. On
parlait de France Télévision par
exemple,
les journalistes médias parfois parce
que tel patron de presse a dit que ou
parce que tel responsable policier a pu
dire là je parle d'un autre secteur
c'est c'est que c'est forcément vrai ou
c'est que c'est forcément vérifié.
Bon déjà là pour le coup c'est donné
beaucoup d'importance paradoxalement à
l'omniscience des services de l'État.
Euh, il y a aussi beaucoup de
défaillance en de ce point de vue-là,
malgré l'évolution technologique, on
pourra venir, mais euh euh il y a euh un
vrai effet euh là euh également de euh
de sous-information et également qui
explique la défiance euh des gens parce
que dans l'accident industriel de du
pont de l'Igoness qui pour moi la presse
là pour le coup porte une responsabilité
extrêmement importante, hein.
Alors bien évidemment, c'est dans
l'urgence
et un quotidien doit doit rendre ça une
à telle heure. Il faut savoir, les gens
le savent peu hein, mais c'est que en 20
ans, la plupart des quotidiens qui sont
aujourd'hui en kiosque ont vu leur
bouclage ramener à des heures de plus en
plus comment dire de moins en moins
tardives. Donc il y a aussi ces
éléments-l à prendre en compte. Mais euh
en réalité euh dans l'affaire euh du
pont ligonis ou de l'UBisol, pour moi,
on assiste plutôt à à un phénomène de
sous-information
et qui amène à euh la défiance du public
parce que le public ne s'y retrouve pas.
Et par ailleurs euh
au sur un plan euh entre guillemet
politique d'une manière générale sur la
déconnexion, on parlait des gilets
jaunes, on pourrait parler d'autres
mouvements sociaux. Euh cette
déconnexion, oui, a un effet euh direct
sur la défiance. et on en revient à ce
que j'essayé d'expliquer. un peu
compliqué parfois mais parce que c'est
peu expliqué mais un à la
survalorisation des sources officielles
dans la presse française et au fait que
la presse française finalement
et et et comme la plupart d'ailleurs des
des élites bon là c'est des comment dire
c'est des movies donc je veux pas
englober tout le monde mais finalement
on est dans un pays légitimiste par
rapport au pouvoir globalement du côté
de des gens qui sont aux manettes et et
la presse souffre de Ça aussi,
c'est-à-dire que euh encore et et ça
explique par exemple pour revenir à
Macron l'extrême prudence des
journalistes à à travailler et à
enquêter sur Macron
parce qu' ils vont plus être sous le
robinet des sources officielles parce
que
alors il y a la question des sources
officielles, il y avait la question des
de la carrière qu'on a évoqué tout à
l'heure.
Source officielle, il faut qu'on rentre
dans le détail.
Oui,
parce que c'est quand même important. La
source officielle, c'est vous êtes
copain avec un ministère, vous
connaissez un mec machin qui est proche
du pouvoir, il vous connaît bien. Comme
vous faites des papiers gentilles sur ce
qui se passe, ils vont vous faire fuiter
de l'information. C'est ça une source
officielle ? C'est pas que de la fuite
hein. Euh quand je dis source
officielles, c'est des gens qui sont en
situation de pouvoir dans les
différentes institutions. Euh et quand
je dis que la presse survalorise ces
sources euh officielles qui ont des
positions de pouvoir dans les
institutions, c'est que souvent euh elle
ne prend pas suffisamment de distance
par rapport aux propres enjeux de
pouvoir dans ces institutions-là. Donc
elle n'apporte pas d'analyse et
décryptage de ce qu'il y a autour de
l'information. euh ce qui pourrait faire
des enquêtes en soi et des analyses en
soi. Et par ailleurs euh euh ils le le
le hiérarchie hein, c'est notamment les
hiérarchie ont du mal. Et pourquoi les
hiérarchies ? C'est parce que
historiquement la presse française, dans
la presse française, les hiérarchies
sont composées principalement d'anciens
journalistes politiques euh bien dressé,
non pas pas bien dressé mais qui ont une
conception du journalisme là pour le
coup extrêmement légitimiste. Voilà.
Euh, ils ont même pas être dressés d'une
certaine manière. Voilà. Euh,
c'est-à-dire que il croi au système
politique. Donc euh, c'est encore mieux.
Euh oui, bah euh alors se regarder dans
la glace.
Oui, oui, oui, d'une certaine manière.
Mais euh bon, ça, il y a plein de
sociologues des médias. Alors, pour
expliquer aux internautes, c'est que
avant de enfin pendant que je me formais
au journalisme, j'ai fait de la
sociologie des médias. Donc euh
qu'est-ce que vous pensez d'ACMED ?
Ils font un boulot intéressant même si
euh là aussi il faut du monde pour
enquêter et de l'argent. Et donc en fait
Arimed existe depuis 1995 he depuis les
mouvements sociaux de de 95 il soit
jamais oublié. Bonjour à Henry Malheur.
Voilà. Et puis euh et puis à Patrick
Champagne cfondateur qui a été mon
directeur de recherche. Là, je fais du
copinage mais ça a été mon directeur de
recherche en en en sociologie euh
jusqu'à une thèse que j'ai pas fini mais
enfin bon passons. Et euh pour revenir à
l'explication sur le rapport aux sources
officielles, euh il y a une
sous-valorisation des outsiders dans les
institutions
euh et une pénalisation aussi
et donc et une
une pénalisation. Alors par ailleurs euh
il y a la question et notamment par
rapport au champ économique du secret
des du secret des affaires. Il y a une
judiciarisation euh des enquêtes euh
parce que il y a des pressions
judiciaires, il y a des des actions
bayon comme on dit vis-à-vis des
journalistes comme des lanceurs d'al
procédure bayon procédure bayon
procédure bayon. J'ai dit quoi ?
Et donc donc voilà et donc il y a
également cet aspect là des choses qui
entre lignent le compte et qui est
extrêmement importante et ça explique
oui que on au nom de l'info, on on
laisse faire davantage les fuites d'une
certaine manière, un certain journalisme
de fuite et donc très instrumentalisé
d'une certaine manière
et également
ça concerne également l'enquête. Euh
c'estàdire ce qu'on entend par enquête
dans les journaux. Euh ça il y a
d'autres gens he qui le disent mieux que
moi. Euh enfin euh par exemple Denis
Robert euh a très bien expliqué que son
départ de libération des années 90 euh
euh était lié aussi de cette
judiciarisation de l'enquête. Ce qui
fait que parce que un les journaux sont
de plus en plus euh acculés au niveau
financier et donc ils ont du mal à
assumer de d'éventuels procès parce que
tout ça ça coûte de l'argent. Euh les
directeurs de journaux, enfin des
rédactions peuvent être directeurs de
publication, donc qui sont responsables
au pénal comme le journaliste, hein,
d'ailleurs euh euh de plus en plus,
hein.
Et donc dans ce dans cette situation là
de de de judiciarisation,
je sais que différents responsables de
rédaction préfèrent de l'enquête qui est
déjà issue d'enquête judiciaire, donc de
faire de la fuite judiciaire ou
policière. Et donc là, on revient sur la
question des sources officielles. Euh
comme si la vérité judiciaire était une
vérité journalistique ou démocratique.
Euh parce que parfois un la justice peut
se tromper, parfois la justice peut être
le relais d'intérêt. Euh voilà, enfin le
monde n'est pas tout blanc, tout noir,
mais
il y a des rapports de force, y compris
au sein de la justice. Et donc
le le la survalorisation
des fuites judiciaires et policières
avec le qualificatif d'enquête participe
de mon point de vue aussi à une défiance
vis-à-vis de la presse parce que ça
alimente le tous pourri, ça alimente le
tous pourri notamment vis-à-vis des
politiques parce que justement c'est
plus facile de faire sortir des petits
scandales judiciarisés sur les
politiques, la tête des politiques. Je
ne dis pas, je fais pas de moral là, je
fais de la de l'analyse he plutôt que
plutôt que sur les scandales sanitaires,
plutôt que sur les très grandes
euh boîte qui ont des enjeux financiers
considérables euh y compris on parlait
du complexe militar industriel ou des ou
des ou des domaines aussi sensibles que
cela.
la la raison d'état aussi dans les
domaines stratégiques. Et donc bien
évidemment, c'est plus facile de faire
du petit scandale. En plus, les gens le
retiennent bien, c'est l'affaire des
Omars par exemple,
plutôt que des enquêtes qui parlent
d'enjeux parfois extrêmement compliqué
mais aussi parfois extrêmement peu
rentable médiatiquement d'un point de
vue du scandale, c'est-à-dire où en fait
c'est des analyses, c'est des
informations stratégiques certes
extrêmement importantes, mais où il y a
pas de scandale apparent alors qu'il n'y
en a de scandales mais euh où les
chaînes d'info vont pas pouvoir dire un
tel a été perquisitionné et compagnie.
Je suis pas en train de jeter la pierre
à mes à mes confrères parce que
moi-même, on parlait de dossier
Bigmalon, moi-même j'ai parfois fait de
la fuite judiciaire ou policière mais
par exemple sur le dossier Bigmalon
c'est même le contraire ce qui c'est de
ce qui la manière comment dire Bigmalon
rappeler succintement le ce que c'est
succintement le dossier Bigmalon et en
fait le dossier du financement de la
campagne électorale enfin de en tout cas
du maquillage du financement de la
campagne électorale de de Nicolas
Sarkozi enfin en tout cas au niveau des
dépenses he au niveau des recettes c'est
intéressant c'est une précision
intéressante.
Et et en fait c'est que la la la
l'équipe de Nicolas Sarkozy en 2012
avait euh totalement dépassé les les
budgets normaux et légaux et légaux
d'une campagne électorale. D'ailleurs,
c'est aux alentours de 22 millions sur
les deux tours et ils avaient en fait
dépensé alors la justice a pris en
compte 40 millions d'euros et moi
j'avais révélé en fait que le chiffre
était entre 50 et 60 millions d'euros si
on prenait en plus les les non les TGV
les TGV à frêter et parce que
paradoxalement la campagne de 2012 de
Nicolas Sarkozy est peut-être l'une des
plus propres de la droite française, ça
c'est pas moi qui le dit, c'est Jérôme
Laavrieux qui en réalité pointe le fait
que à l'époque en 2012 il y avait déjà
des enquê quête sur financement illégal
présumé venant de la Libye en 2007 hein,
révélé par Media Part et euh et donc la
la les équipes de Nicolas Sarkozy ont
très peu utilisé de liquide en 2012.
C'est pour ça qu'il fallait maquiller
les dépenses justement. Bon, donc j'ai
travaillé sur ce dossier Big Malon et
justement j'ai plutôt visé euh les
équipes de Nicolas Sarkoziier de
campagne pour dire l'affaire Big Malon
concerne la campagne plutôt que euh de
de dire que c'était une caisse noire
pour Jean-François Copé et pour ses
équipes. Bon, au final peut-être que ça
a été un peu des deux. En tout cas, moi
j'ai pas d'éléments factuels qui me le
montrent. J'ai plutôt des éléments
factuels qui montrent le contraire. Et
d'ailleurs, le juge Serge Tourner a été
dans euh euh l'analyse que j'en avais
faite assez rapidement comme d'autres
confrères d'ailleurs, mais euh euh dès
enfin dès 2014 quand le scandale entre
guillemets est arrivé par le magazine Le
Point au départ. Et là, c'est important
parce que en fait, on était en amont de
la justice pour le coup. Euh et euh j'ai
une partie de mes enquêtes qui ont été
intégrées au dossier d'instruction du
juge sur Serge Tourner. C'est-à-dire que
la justice et notamment les juges
d'instruction ont parfois besoin pas
directement mais parce que en fait c'est
très difficile aujourd'hui même il y a
20 ans quand on dit le gouvernement des
juges et la presse qui est comment dire
abreuvé des juges en fait c'est beaucoup
moins les juges qui abreuvent les
journalistes que les avocats.
des avocats qui ont des intérêts de
défense. Déjà, parfois, il peut y avoir
des sources judiciaires type greffier,
des sources interne à la justice, mais
les juges d'instruction font quand même
extrêmement attention à préserver le
secret de l'instruction parce que eux
sont soumis au secret de l'instruction
et donc les fuites sont pas comme ça. Le
juge le juge rouge comme les appelle
parfois le clan SarkoZi nous attaque et
donne le PV à tel journaliste, tel
journaliste non, les choses sont plus
compliquées. Et parfois quand il y a des
fuites judiciaires, c'est notamment
parce que l'institution et notamment le
parquet qui est relativement indépendant
en France ou d'une qui est indépendant
d'une manière relative si je reste
prudent euh et bien parfois c'est quand
les juges d'instruction quand les
enquêteurs ont besoin d'avancer sur leur
enquête et donc ont besoin de la presse
comme là pour le coup d'un système de
contrepouvoir contre institution
judiciaire elle-même et politique pour
dire attention là il y a un scandale et
Donc, on a besoin de révéler les choses
y compris par la presse et d'être aidé
par des journalistes à ce moment-là.
Donc là, on voit bien qu'on est dans un
système un écosystème complexe.
Mais pour revenir à à ce que
j'expliquais sur le jour de manisme
plus instrumentalisé qui qui ne fait que
relayer parfois que des fuites,
et bien effectivement ça a quand même un
effet. C'est-à-dire que la presse euh
n'analyse pas les rapports de force sur
un secteur, les enjeux, les bisbilles
réels, parfois extrêmement complexes,
euh parfois avec des enjeux financiers
extrêmement importants et vont vont être
euh dans la comment dire dans le
suivisme et euh
ils vont, on va dire, avoir des attaques
entre guillemets euh attaques en tout
cas des révélations euh enfin quand la
presse va sans enclencher parfois les
les les révélations sur une affaire
parce que en gros ça sera pas très
comment dire ça sera pas très dangereux
d'un point de vue politique personnel ou
tout ce que vous voulez enfin c'estàd
que ça il y a d'autres journalistes qui
l'ont bien expliqué hein la presse elle
lèche elle lynche lâche elle lynche ou
elle lynche elle lâche. Il y a il y a
voilà mais il y a il y a il y a il y a
un effet moutonnier de la presse pour
revenir à la défiance et moutonnier
voilà qui est lié à une sous-information
parce que un sous-pluralisme de
l'information
parce que en réalité c'est pareil là
j'ai un
j'ai un avis un peu différencié parfois
sur certains discours. Il y a pas il y a
pas des faits qui seraient objectifs.
des faits sont des éléments eux-mêmes.
Une information et d'abord aussi un
comment dire une construction des
journalistes mêmes qui décident d'avoir
tel titre, de mettre en avant telle
information, d'avoir telle analyse sur
tel sujet. Donc tout ça euh n'est pas
d'un côté, il y a des faits qui seraient
totalement objectifs, euh
scientifiquement euh prouvés comme si on
comme si on avait pas chimiquement pur,
comme si on avait pas découvert Einstein
donc euh quand même et de l'autre côté
euh euh euh que des que le monde des
opinions. Après ce qui est c'est vrai,
la difficulté aujourd'hui de faire du
journalisme et je le je le perçois parce
que c'est parfois c'est des critiques
qu'on don d don dont je fais l'objet,
c'est "Ah mais il est trop prudent, il
va pas plus loin, il est il est pas
assez dans la dénonciation". Oui, mais
euh ça c'est la difficulté aujourd'hui,
c'est que le public notamment euh via
Facebook, les réseaux sociaux euh il y a
un effet extrêmement pervers. C'estàd
que le public quand vous leur vous
délivrez des informations euh pas
forcément brutes, même parfois avec une
analyse, mais des informations d'ordre
stratégique.
Euh par exemple là, j'ai fait une
récente enquête sur EDF et la question
du nucléaire par exemple où j'en parlais
d'ailleurs dans dans mon enquête sur
Macron mois d'avril dernier, on on va
réunir, mais sur le fait que je révélais
le le le plan qui s'est appelé Hercule
de Sission de DF et une éventuelle
relance du nucléaire en France. Et euh
ça ça ça ne fait pas beaucoup de bruit
euh ces ces informations stratégiques
alors qu'elles sont extrêmement
stratégiques. Et ça pose une question
démocratique parce que ces informations
stratégiques sont de plus en plus euh
sont de plus en plus partagées entre
initiés, y compris par des lettres
confidentielles où il faut s'abonner
très cher pour avoir accès à cette
information. Euh même aujourd'hui un
journal, une institution comme le monde
coûte extrêmement cher à acheter en
kiosque. Euh euh et donc en fait ça ça
explique aussi la défiance. C'estàd que
et ça peut expliquer aussi le
conformisme pour revenir au conformisme
d'idée, c'est que quand le public de la
presse est plutôt CSP+ et a plutôt
tendance à voter pour quelqu'un plutôt
que pour un autre, ça explique un
affadissement
du pluralisme y compris au sein de la
presse. Et ça ça a des conséquences
directes. pour parler de Marianne par
exemple, c'est un peu une incongruité
dans les news mag Marianne parce que
c'est
un magazine qui a comment dire boulot
quand même hein.
Oui. Parfois, je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord sur sur des certains sujets,
mais mais
et puis le problème de Marianne, par
exemple, c'est la question de la
crédibilité du journal et notamment en
terme d'information parce que une marque
d'information et une crédibilité, ça se
fait pas en un jour, c'est extrêmement
compliqué et et crédibilité en terme de
reprise d'information notamment par la
FP, par les autres grands médias qui
font caisse de résonance. Or, les
sources, elles ont besoin d'avoir aussi
cette caisse de résonance et quand elles
en ont pas euh ben elles ont plutôt
tendance à aller ailleurs. Euh bon, mais
c'est donc cette question
quoi ça ? Bon,
bah parce que c'est pas non, j'ai pas
envie d'en parler, c'est non parce que
ça serait encore ouvrir un autre sujet.
Euh mais on peut on peut ouvrir un autre
sujet. Euh
bon, alors on va ouvrir un autre sujet.
Euh
c'est que j'aime j'ouvre plein de de
poupées russes mais j'aime bien les
refermer. Voilà, chacun
on laisse notre communauté les refermer,
nous apporter un complément
d'information.
Oui, tout à fait. Mais le c'est qu'il y
a il y a par exemple par rapport à la
neutralisation des informations, il y a
un truc qui est totalement sous-estimé
parce que là on peut pour le coup on est
totalement dans la tambouille, on va
dire des enquêtes euh enfin de ce qu'on
appelle enquête ou investigation, ça
c'est le grand mot. Euh mais
c'est que un journaliste n'est pas
indépendant vis-à-vis de ses sources. il
est il peut avoir une plus ou moins
grande autonomie vis-à-vis de ces
sources et justement en les multipliant
sur un même sujet justement en
recoupant. Mais quand il n'a que que peu
de source et en en situation de
dépendance par rapport à ces sources, là
déjà ça peut être ça peut créer de la
malinformation. Mais surtout euh à un
moment donné quand il y a des sources
qui sont pourvoyeuses, beaucoup
d'information, euh ça crée un canal
d'information. Et parfois ces sources-là
euh elles ne sont pas là aussi toutes
blanches. Euh elles ont aussi leurs
propres intérêts. Et donc ça c'est pour
ça que la diminution des équipes de
journalistes dans les journaux a une
conséquence directe, c'est que euh
comment dire c'est très difficile pour
un un journaliste de pouvoir enquêter
sur tous les sujets comme une rédaction
d'ailleurs. tout simplement parce que
elles ont leur rapport aux sources et
elles vont avoir plutôt du mal ou à être
dans la réserve à enquêter sur leurs
propres sources, sauf quand elles
s'aperçoivent qu'à un moment donné elles
ne peuvent plus faire autrement.
Qu'est-ce que je veux dire par là ?
C'est que parfois il y a certaines
sortties d'informations qui peuvent être
aussi instrumentalisé par ce biais là de
ce rapport là aux sources. Et ça c'est
quelque chose qui ça c'est ça c'est
quelque chose qui est sous-estimé y
compris par le grand public parce que
euh ah c'est une enquête c'est de
l'investigation donc on en revient à
ça ça serait ça serait sorti d'un jeu de
rapport de force. Ça c'est pas pour
relativiser le travail d'enquête, c'est
pour vraiment l'expliquer en profondeur.
Enfin j'essaie de l'expliquer en
profondeur. Je sais que c'est
relativement peu fait normalement y
compris par par rapport à certains de
mes confrères. Mais euh c'est une vraie
euh c'est c'est un vrai élément à
comprendre également. Euh voilà, mais
sur la question de la crédibilité
de tout à l'heure et sur la crédibilité
des informations et le fait de la la
caisse de résonance, la question la
question de la crédibilisation d'une
information vis-à-vis de l'ensemble du
système médiatique extrêmement
importante, difficile à avoir euh parce
que là aussi c'est pareil, le système
médiatique va ne va pas comment dire euh
va en fait va faire confiance à d'autres
institutions. Et donc quand on est hors
institution, c'est très difficile de
valoir la crédibilité de ces
informations. Ça a été le cas par
exemple au début de la création de Méia
Part, ça a été le cas de la de d'autres
journaux aujourd'hui de faire valoir la
crédibilité de ces informations par
rapport à des institutions comme une
caisse de résonance qui est particulière
dont on n pas encore parlé dans le
système français qui est la FP et qui
abreuve beaucoup les journaux et et ça
ça ça a une incidence. C'est en gros
quelle est la bonne information qui va
être totalement rendue publique et celle
qui serait considérée comme moins bonne
euh par le reste de la profession. Et ça
c'est extrêmement important là y compris
dans la hiérarchie des informations de
l'ensemble de l'écosystème médiatique.
Il y a une enquête
d'une étude qui a été faite par le MIT
euh et qui a été relé par un institut
euh très libéral voir néolibéral qui est
un institut de montagne. Mais pour le
coup il faisait une étude très
intéressante sur la presse française.
C'est d'ailleurs des chercheurs
américains. C'est peut-être ceci
explique cela. Mais l'étude, qu'est-ce
qu'elle a montré ? c'est que
paradoxalement la presse américaine dont
on glorifie le rapport au fait, la la
dont on mytifie le rapport aux enquêtes,
au reportages et effectivement il y a
des raisons à Smith, mais des raisons
comment dire là de moyens, de culture,
d'enquête, de rapport à la
l'organisation des rédactions, le
rapport juridique également aux avocats
et à toutes ces choses-là. Mais euh la
grand la grande conclusion de cette
étude-là montrait qu'en fait les médias
américains euh étaient beaucoup plus
polarisé sur le plan politique qu'on
veut bien qu'on voulait bien le dire.
Euh c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des chaînes
d'infos qui sont clairement euh euh très
conservatrices ou démocrates euh et en
France on est dans une idéologie
professionnelle de la neutralité des
journalistes, de l'objectivité. En
réalité l'objectivité, il y a quelques
il y a je crois que c'était hier soir
sur le plateau de quotidien, il y avait
la présence Dian Bart
euh
Joker. Enfin, on on reviendra après mais
je veux finir mon idée. Attendez. Euh
euh
il il interrogeait euh Anneclercoudray,
je crois, je je regarde plus trop le le
JT de du venteur de TF1. et elle a dit
quelque chose qui était incroyable d'une
certaine manière d'un point de vue
sociologique parce qu'elle a dit euh je
n'ai je n'ai pas avoir d'influence ou
d'opinion
parce que mon public est tellement
large, c'estàdire des millions de
téléspectateurs, nous n'avons pas
intérêt à avoir une opinion par rapport
à ce public large qui ne pense pas la
même chose. Et donc en fait
l'objectivité en fait c'est un
construit. C'est un construit par
rapport aux médias au grands médias qui
ont des problématiques d'audience et
donc il ne peuvent pas cliver en
développant des opinions. Et donc comme
la presse française, la presse écrite
mais la presse audiovisuelle française,
il y a un rapport de force inversé en
France. C'est-à-dire que les médias
audiovisuels, y compris dans le cadre de
la 5e République et c'estàdire qui est
toute focalisé sur la présidentielle
dans même le débat entre deux tours,
même si on peut penser que le débat
d'entreur d'entre deux tours a moins
d'influence politique, on le dit
aujourd'hui, mais euh euh tout est
polarisé sur la télévision et la et la
et la radio principalement aujourd'hui.
C'est eux qui ont le pouvoir dans le
débat politique principalement après
avec les sondages d'opinion, les
communiquants et tout ça, mais ça a des
affaires extrêmement importants y
compris sur la presse et justement sur
la pluralité de la presse et
l'information et l'étude de l'Institut
montagne qui a été relayé par des médias
comme Libération d'ailleurs et et de de
du MIT expliquait quoi ? expliquer
justement cette chose là très
particulière de l'espace médiatique
français, c'est-à-dire un les français
les journalistes français se réfugient
dans une présentation professionnelle
pour pas parler d'idéologie mais c'est
l'idéologie de neutralité d'objectivité
alors que tout est tout est décidé tout
est subjectif d'une certaine manière je
veux pas être dans le relativisme bien
évidemment mais un titre c'est c'est un
choix et tout choix et est et doit être
assumé vocable le vocable qui va avec
et le vocable qui avec le vocabulaire le
titre
quand on fait un reportage télé, l'image
qu'on choisit, ces choses-là. Donc euh
là encore, il y a pas un éther du
journalisme et ça c'est très français,
les concepts, la philosophie, tout ça
serait un é donc il y a pas ça mais la
la la l'étude et je veux juste finir sur
la conclusion, après on parlera bien de
Martinas, mais euh la la conclusion sur
l'étude euh c'était que les les médias
français 1 étaient eux-mêmes dans une le
relais de cette neutralité
enfin de affirmer comme tel. J'ai pas
dit qu'ils étaient neutres. Euh et euh
et par ailleurs, ils s'autocitent entre
eux en fonction des médias qui sont
considérés comme légitimes et des médias
qui sont considérés pas comme pas
légitimes. Et moi, comme j'ai travaillé
pour des journaux euh pourtant parfois
des illustres journaux comme témoignage
chrétien mais qu'un tout petit journal
maintenant de de 5000 abonnés mais qui
qui a fait plus de 200000 exemplaires
dans les années 60 où j'ai travaillé
pour le monde diplomatique ou pour
Marianne et puis pour d'autres journaux
parfois plus. conformiste entre
guillemets dans les idées mais
globalement j'ai pas travaillé pour des
institutions de presse et j'ai remarqué
cela, c'estd que les les les
institutions de presse s'autocitent en
France et ça crée de la neutralisation
alors qu'aux États-Unis en réalité c'est
beaucoup plus fluide et par ailleurs et
c'est beaucoup moins, j'allais dire si
je parle casche beaucoup moins focus
parce que on peut faire de la très bonne
enquête en étant euh très coloré
politiquement. Ce n'est pas grave. La
question c'est l'honnêteté par rapport à
cette enquête au fait et alors il y a
certaines personnes qui disent pensez
contre soi, je vais pas je vais pas être
dans la caricature mais c'est pas parce
qu'on a des opinions. Moi par exemple je
suis de gauche, c'est clairement
affiché.
Et bien c'est pas parce qu'on a des
opinions qu'on peut pas enquêter sur des
des structures de gauche qu'on peut pas
dévoiler des informations.
Ça se fait pas ça.
Ça se fait pas.
Ça se fait pas. On le voit pas trop.
Ça se fait d'une manière minoritaire.
Oui, mais parce que là encore parce que
c'est tout c'est toute la tradition
française qui fait que paradoxalement on
veut que les journalistes soient neutres
globalement. Enfin là je dis on veut les
les les y compris les gros médias. Et en
réalité il y a une il y a il y a comment
dire il y a il y a une surpolitisation
c'est tout le paradoxe. Il y a une
surpolitisation en coulisse.
Bouge pas, il faut que je réponde.
Je sais pas si
je vois c'est parfaitement
compréhensible. D'ailleurs, vous faites
quoi à Noël ? J'ai besoin de quelqu'un
pour aller dîner avec moi pendant les
fêtes pour expliquer ça à ma famille et
je vous propose de vous louer pour les
dîners des fêtes.
J'espère j'ai été compréhensible parce
que je suis allé dans tous les sens et
non non. Donc Yan Bartes, on lance la la
Yan Bartz. Marz, quoi dire ? que je
regarde Yan Marz. Voilà, je suis dévoilé
euh parce que après une longue journée
euh voilà, après une longue journée,
parfois il y a il y a vraiment pas
grand-chose à la télé française.
Oui, oui, la télé bien sûr, il y a SW et
euh euh Non, il y a une partesse,
on est dans l'affontainment comme on
dit, hein. Donc, on est dans en fait,
c'est un mélange des genres qui peut
apparaître comme sympathique. Euh je dis
sympathique entre guillemets par rapport
de mon point de vue par rapport à Éric
Zemour sur C News par exemple. Voilà.
Euh après bien évidemment que ils ont
leur ligne éditoriale, ils ont leurs
préférences on va dire. Je vais pas
employer ce terme là mais je vais quand
même l'employer. Mais bon
un certain politiquement correct. Euh
euh bon et donc euh donc euh voilà, ils
sont dans la fontainement quoi. Et donc
en fait euh ils ont des grandes
prétentions euh journalistiques
d'ailleurs euh parce qu'il euh ça fait
partie de leur marketing. Il d'ailleurs
ils embauchent des journalistes, c'est
vrai. Euh ils parlent beaucoup des
journalistes, ils ils invitent des
journalistes d'ailleurs. Euh
mais euh mais en réalité en en réalité
il ils font ils font pas d'enquête. il
sortent pas de sujet. Enfin voilà, c'est
une émission de divertissement
principalement.
Bon, maintenant qu'on a fait les PR
Mais ça ça a atteint son public. Bon
voilà, mais bon ça pose des conséquences
d'ailleurs. Enfin
bon, maintenant qu'on a fait les
préliminaires pour faire la présentation
de Marc Andevel à la communauté les
préliminaires. Ouais, c'est
c'est c'est sympa. C'est
et on va pouvoir parler de Macron parce
que maintenant qu'on a qu'on a dévoilé
Marc Andevel sa psychologie, sa
perception de la presse, comment il
enquête, comment tout ça maintenant on
va voir
pas encore tout he
non mais là la Macronie, les réseaux
cachés de Macron. Alors déjà pourquoi ce
bouquin ? Comment vous avez enquêté ?
Ça, on a compris. Euh c'est quoi ces
fameux réseaux cachés, ces réseaux
secrets ? et on va rentrer dans la
macronie par le petit trou.
Alors bah c'est bien. Alors je vais
expliquer comment
ça sert à rien de se renfermer de
croiser les nois croiser les jambes
hein.
D'ailleurs vous avez eu des procès avec
le bouquin ou pas ?
Aucun procès. Mais là aussi c'est pareil
c'est pas parce qu'on a des procès que
ce qu'on raconte est faux. Déjà petit
point important. Petit point important.
La diffamation c'est l'atteinte à la
honneur de quelqu'un. Donc même si vous
délivrez une information vraie et
qu'elle atteint à l'honneur de la
personne, euh vous pouvez être attaqué
et condamné pour diffamation. Il y a des
éléments euh pris en compte par la
jurisprudence et les tribunaux et les
tribunaux de presse comme la 17e chambre
correctionnelle de tribunal de Paris euh
euh qui est la bonne foi du journaliste
et la le sérieux de l'enquête, euh le
respect du contradictoire euh tout que
des bon des éléments qui entrent en
ligne de compte qui fait que même si
potentiellement ça peut avoir une inte à
l'honneur de la personne, le journaliste
est n'est pas condamné. Mais euh euh
dans les faits euh c'est euh comment
dire au au niveau d'une comment dire euh
d'une attaque judiciaire, c'est le
journaliste contrairement à d'autres
procès, qui doit faire preuve de sa
bonne foi et qui doit prouver avec des
éléments euh comment dire des preuves,
qui doit prouver les éléments factuels,
c'est-à-dire des témoignages de gens au
procès. Et donc, il y a des sources qui
ne veulent pas et c'est bien elles ont
elles ont elles ont elles va avoir leur
raison. de de témoigner au procès, ça
peut être des documents et parfois on n'
pas accès à des documents. Et donc euh
ce que là aussi je mets une nuance,
c'est pas parce qu'un journaliste est
condamné que ce qu'il a dit était faux.
C'est quand même important aussi parce
que sinon ça participe de la
judiciarisation de la presse qui de mon
point de vue que voilà et et et qui est
pas non plus qu' dire qui est une
judiciarisation de la presse y compris
dans la tête des gens. C'est pas
uniquement le fait des grands groupes
effectivement qui ont des bataillons
d'avocats et de communiquants. C'est
aussi dans la tête des gens où en fait
il y aurait les trucs qui seraient
judiciarisés entre guillemets, enfin qui
qui aurait passé le visa de la justice.
Et d'ailleurs, ça c'est une petite
anecdote qui revient qui revient à mon
livre. par exemple, j'ai été euh invité
sur le plateau de Donc j'ai pas été
invité chez Yan Bartes, mais j'ai j'ai
été invité euh euh sur le plateau de
d'une de ses amies Maitena Bergben euh
l'ancienne animatrice de de Canal Plus
sur RMC,
gagné son procès
euh sur RMC euh oui qui a gagné son
procès contre Boloré et euh et donc euh
elle m'a présenté à plusieurs reprises
dans l'interview euh comme journaliste
d'investigation. Alors, elle insistait
lourdement. C'est vrai que derrière le
livre, c'est écrit journaliste
d'investindication. Bon et elle
insistait lourdement et sur le moment,
bon, c'est une interview qui était
extrêmement courte, c'est pas comme là.
Et donc je me demandais mais pourquoi
elle insiste autant ? Pourquoi elle
insiste autant ? Et en fait, elle
insistait autant parce que en réalité,
elle était en énorme défiance à l'égard
de mon livre, de mon enquête, y compris
pour des raisons de d'avocat du diable.
C'est c'est le c'est la c'est la
journaliste audiovisuelle qui donc ne
prend pas partie entre guillemets par
rapport à une information qui lui est
transmise. Euh mais ça ça a pu être le
cas pour plein d'autres enquêtes he par
exemple confè à faire Kusac par exemple
où c'était aux enquêteurs de prouver
tout à leur confrères qu'ils étaient
dans le vrai. Et donc je reviens à Maita
Beramen parce que elle m'a elle a eu
cette remarque qui expliquait pourquoi
elle insistait sur journaliste
d'investigation. C'était "Mais quelles
sont vos preuves ?" Il y a pas et et
il y a pas il y a pas eu de procès au
sens il y a pas eu de procès sur
certains faits révélés que je racontais.
Et donc sur le moment, j'ai j'ai même
pas réussi à lui répondre parce que ça a
été trop vite. Mais justement, c'est ça
que je voulais dire sur euh la la
comment dire le comment dire l'effet
pervers de la judiciarisation, y compris
de l'enquête, y compris dans sa
perception. C'est-à-dire que pour elle,
une enquête c'était forcément une
affaire judiciaire et que s'il y avait
pas affaire judiciaire, ça n'existait
pas. Il n'y avait pas d'information.
Voilà. Et pourquoi elle faisait ça ?
Pour se protéger. Parce que bien
évidemment si le journaliste se réfugie
derrière l'institution judiciaire c'est
plus facile y comp
hein
c'est comme le chat perché
oui enfin voilà et donc euh euh et en
fait je suis sorti du plateau, je me
suis dit mais en fait en fait elle
parlait de journaliste d'investigation
en fait qui font uniquement des fuites
judiciaires et et voilà et et tout est
d'une certaine manière tout tout était
dit tout est dit alors qu'une enquête
euh comment dire doit apporter des faits
mais parfois des prés présomption de
fait des éléments qui peuvent amener à
une analyse et qui peuvent amener à à
une certaine compréhension des rapport
de force sur un sujet ou certain
déroulement de de ce qui s'est passé
parce que là aussi
la macronie
voilà bon je vais revenir à la macronie
là ça fait un peu tunnel je suis obligé
là je vois je vois les gens dans sur
Macron il faut
et ben alors on va parler donc je
reviens à Macron
il faut que ça tape là
donc la question de Macron
Euh
donc
bon, est-ce que vous avez voté Macron
au deuxème tour ?
Content
passon Joker. Euh
alors mais
alors la question de Macron en fait euh
Macron je le suis depuis pou bientôt 6
ans.
Vous avez anticipé ça le fait qu'il
allait se présenter ? Oui, oui, je suis
Oui, oui. J'ai j'ai dit j'ai dit alors
j'ai dit trop timidement, mais euh j'ai
dit effectivement dans mon premier livre
parce que donc j'ai fait un premier
livre euh qui s'appelle l'ambigu,
monsieur Macron et dans ce premier
livre, j'annonce euh qu'il va peut-être
se présenter dès 2017. 6 mois avant la
Constitution d'Enmarche, j'ai compris
qu'il allait monter un mouvement adocant
par les réseaux sociaux, contournant les
partis politiques, qu'il était en train
de tuer entre guillemets euh Hollande et
Vals dans les coulisses. Euh et ce
bouquin sort en novembre 2015 euh qui a
eu son petit succès d'estime euh sauf
qu'il sort 17 novembre 2015, donc 4
jours après les attentats. Euh donc
bah donc les si je suis enfin cynique du
point de vue des communiquants de
Macron, ils étaient bien contents de la
situation parce qu'en fait les
communiquants de Macron avaient très
peur du bouquin parce que je révélais
leur timing et et j'étais en avance sur
leur timing. Et donc à l'époque Macron
ne voulait pas se présenter comme
concurrent de Hollande ou de Vals, sinon
il serait fait totalement écrabouillé
par la machine institutionnelle. Et donc
à l'époque quand les bonnes feuilles
sont sorties donc confraternellement et
peut-être par copinage mais dans
Marianne euh la cover de Marianne tout
le monde l'a oublié mais c'était Macron
avec une grosse tête et c'était écrit
moi président. Voilà le livre enquête
qui dévoile une ambition. Donc ça c'est
le point de départ mais en fait un an
auparavant j'avais déjà enquêté pour le
magazine et j'avais fait h pages
d'enquête sur une enquête qui
s'intitulait le chouchou des élites et
où j'avais déjà découvert des trucs
particulièrement on va dire bizarres
bah comme le fait que Macron quand il
était passé à la commission il s'est
rapproché des journalistes de la
commission hein donc il y avait Éric le
boucher des échos bon ça c'est pas très
c'est c'est pas une révélation mais il
s'était rapproché par exemple d've de
Cardrel yve de Cardrel qui était le
patron de valeur actuelle à l'époque.
Donc ça dénotait euh on va dire une
psychologie surtout un positionnement
politique beaucoup plus complexe, on a
bien voulu le dire en tout cas à
l'époque du social libéral de c'est un
mélange de Tony Blair d'Hollande et euh
et de la droite du PS par exemple et et
donc ça je l'avais compris aussi très
tôt que le bonhomme jouait sur tous les
tableaux, jouit sur la droite, la gauche
même parfois la droite droite comme
parfois la gauche gauche. Je fais je
fais copain copains avec la gauche du PS
ou avec certains syndicalistes. On
pourrait parler de Pierre Feracii qui
était un de ses amis qui travaille pour
les syndicat la CGT. Alors c'est pas un
mec très à gauche aujourd'hui fait
Pierre Ferchi mais son groupe fait des
rapports pour les comités d'entreprise
pour les syndicats et son fils Marc
Feratcii est le témoin de mariage de
Macron. Et je reviens à à l'antériorité
de l'enquête.
Euh oui, effectivement, je me suis mis
très tôt à travailler sur Macron
notamment euh notamment parce que
il y a un problème ? Non
non non non, on a on va faire un peu de
modération sur un pseudo là.
D'accord. Et donc euh Oui. Donc en fait
qu'est-ce qui m'a amené à Macron déjà ?
Qu'est-ce qui m'a amené à Macron ? Et
d'une, c'est que je me suis aperçu que
dès le début du quinquena Hollande,
euh Hollande était bien plus proche des
grands patrons qu'on a bien voulu le
dire. Euh c'est-à-dire que les médias
notamment de gauche ont cadré le fouet
de Sarkozy, l'ami des grands patrons.
Hollande serait pas l'ami des grands
patrons. Ce qui était en partie vraie
sur son parcours politique, c'est
principalement constitué par le parti
par le Parti socialiste. Sauf qu'en
2012, une partie de l'oligarchie
économique a voté Hollande contre
Sarkozy. Parce que ce qui s'est passé en
2012, c'est qu'une partie de
l'oligarchie économique ne pouvait plus
supporter Nicolas Sarkozi. Il faut le
savoir. Et donc là-dedans, il y avait à
la fois des grands patrons qui étaient
historiquement chirakiens et qui étaient
restés purement chimiquement pur
chirakien et qui voulait se venger des
baladuriens et donc de SarkoZ. D'où le
fait que par exemple François Pinot dans
le luxe est appelé à voter Hollande. Il
a dit qu'il allait voter Hollande
d'ailleurs avant le premier tour. Tout
le monde l'a oublié ça où ça explique
pourquoi quelqu'un d'aussi proche de
Nicolas Sarkozy que Martin Big à
l'époque n'avait pas décidé de soutenir
Nicolas Sarkozy en 2012.
Ce qui explique d'ailleurs que des
copains de Nicolas Sarkozy comme les
journalistes Gérard Carou, Charles
Villeneuve, jeappelle journaliste, je
suis gentil et également Étienne
Moujotte, ancien patron de TF1 avait
créé le groupe Fourtou pour faire du
lobbing pour Nicolas Sarkozy parce
qu'ils avaient compris que TF1 pour une
fois en 2012, c'est pas qu'il ferait la
campagne de Hollande mais que TF1 ne
ferait pas la campagne de SarkoZi et ça
peut peser quand en TF1 a encore des
millions de téléspectateurs. Ça c'est la
c'était la situation de départ qui a eu
des conséquences parce que Emmanuel
Macron à l'époque venait de la banque
Rotschield, venait de la commission
Atalie, de l'énarme tout ça je l'ai
raconté dans le premier livre, ça a été
raconté de multiples fois normal
et a échoué effectivement trois fois
Normal Supmanuel
Macron était au cœur d'une partie de ses
proximités de grand patron par exemple
une partie d'une institution qui
s'appelle la FEP qui est LA FEP c'est
les représentants des grandes
multinationales françaises. C'est une
sorte de MEDEF mais pour les grandes
pour les grandes multinationales. Voilà,
c'est le High level, c'est euh c'est les
très grands patrons qui se regroupent en
club qui euh alors que le MEDF a aussi
les petites entreprises et euh les
moyennes entreprises et la FEP, dans la
FEP, il y a énormément de grands patrons
qui sont en fait des anciens haut
fonctionnaires du Parti socialiste des
années 80 qui par le tournant libéral de
Fabus sont devenus ensuite grand patron
d'entreprise, le pantouflage et
compagnie. Et donc par exemple, il y a
beaucoup de patrons de la FEP qui
étaient derrière François Hollande et
c'est pas étonnant après de les
retrouver dans le giron d'Emmanuel
Macron. Donc c'est comme ça que je suis
arrivé en partie sur le personnage
d'Emal Macron, c'est qu'en fait au
départ, je voulais enquêter sur les
rapports entre François Hollande et les
grands patrons. Voilà, ça c'est le
premier point de départ. Deuxième point
de départ. Deuxième point de départ,
c'est qu'il y a euh quelqu'un que
maintenant qui est très connu mais que
j'avais que j'avais dans mes contacts et
qui avait lu mon bouquin sur France
Télévision qui s'appelle Ran Branc et
qui m'avait dit
"Quel rapport vous entretenez avec lui ?
C'est une question d'internet ?"
Euh depuis 6 mois, j'ai plus aucun
contact avec lui. Voilà. Euh mais j'ai
pas j'ai j'ai pas de rapport quoi.
Voilà. Après après le passé, c'est le
passé puis le passé, je peux pas trop en
parler parce que là pour le coup c'est
c'est j'ai parfois des rapports
professionnels. J'ai eu des des rapports
professionnels. Mais euh euh
il me dit à l'époque euh il faut euh
on se su toi il ça c'est pour répondre à
la question. Il faut que tu enquêtes sur
Emmanuel Macron.
Euh ça donc on est en 2014 mais à
l'époque il n'explique pas qu'il a eu
son fameux déjeuner ou dîner qu'il a eu
avec Xavier Niel en janvier 2014. Et
donc c'est aussi Ran Branco, mais
d'autres gens là que je je terraai le
nom. Euh on va dire là, j'ai dévoilé
entre guillemets ce qui pourrait
s'apparenter à une source, on va dire ça
comme ça, mais en tout cas un contact
que j'avais à l'époque. Euh il y a
d'autres gens qui commencent à
m'ambiancer sur il faut que vous vous
enquiétez sur Emmanuel Macron parce que
il commence à se préparer.
Alors ça s'est fait en plusieurs étapes
parce que justement les gens, ça aussi
c'est faut ce que les les auditeurs les
auditeurs les internautes comprennent,
c'est que comme les sources ont leurs
intérêts personnels et divers et variés,
ils vont pouvoir vous mettre sur une
piste mais vous dévoiler 5 % de la
réalité à au moment. Ça c'est pour
expliquer une chose parce que les gens
disent "Ah mais comment ça se fait que
les journalistes ont pas enquêté sur
Emmanuel Macron avant la campagne
présidentielle Bah, il y a un effet
structurel, c'est que bon, déjà encore
une fois, il y a peu d'enquêtes dans la
presse française, mais deuxièmement,
c'est que l'enquête, ça prend du temps.
Et troisièmement, c'est le rapport aux
sources. C'estàd que euh euh comment
dire Emmanuel Macron en 2014 quand j'ai
commencé à enquêter sur lui, il y avait
très peu de sources qui avaient intérêt
de parler euh de de parler à de sur
Emmanuel Macron parce que c'était l'ami
de tout le monde à l'époque, droite
gauche confondu, les grands patrons.
Donc ces gens-là quand ils vous
parlaient d'Emmanel Macron, ils ne vous
disaient pas toute la vérité et surtout
ils avaient un discours euh euh
extrêmement positif. Enfin bon et donc
moi ma première enquête, j'ai quand même
et notamment ce qui a donné le livre,
j'ai dû ramer pour avoir des
informations et j'en ai quand même
sorti. Donc j'ai j'ai fat checké son CV,
j'ai expliqué qu'effectivement il avait
raté Normal Suprairement à la rumeur que
il avait raté une première fois LEN. Ça
c'est pour son CV que c'était pas le
génie comme on le présentait
aux art de la fin. Voilà, j'ai j'ai je
je dévoile à ce moment-là toute une
bonne partie du réseau économique qu'il
a, la commission Atali, je fais tout un
chapitre sur sur la banque Shield et par
ailleurs, je raconte un épisode dont les
gens ont parlé après par la suite, le
fameux épisode où il il conseille à
titre bénévole la société des rédacteurs
du monde alors qu'en réalité il est dans
l'enfre concurrente avec Prisa, Alain
Min et Orange qui essaie de mettre la
main sur le monde alors qu'en face il y
a Berger, Niel Pigas. Et donc je raconte
cet épisode où Macron dans tout un
chapitre, ça s'appelle 10 avenue George
5, 10, je sais plus, enfin ça c'est
l'adresse exacte des bureaux d'Allemin
mais bon voilà c'est passé euh le le le
dans ce chapitre là les journalistes de
la société des rédacteurs du monde
s'aperçoivent que Macron vient de sortir
des bureaux d'Ainc et qu'il est à la
fois en contact avec Alamin et ancien
membre du du conseil d'administration du
monde il y a une quinzaine d'années
auparavant et représentant on va du
grand du grand capital pour les
journalistes une partie des journalistes
du monde et donc il ils se sont sentis
trahi à l'époque et ça montrait quoi ?
Ça montrait la duplicité de Macron qui
est un terme que lui-même utilise à
d'autres moments dans sa campagne
électorale. "Non, je ne suis pas
duplice", dit-il. En réalité, Emmanuel
Macron a souvent utilisé des justement
comme un banquier d'affaires des réseaux
adverses, des réseaux qui ont des
intérêts différents pour son propre
intérêt et il s'est souvent placé au
milieu que tant d'un point de vue
économique banquier d'affaires que d'un
point de vue là sur les affaires de
presse ou d'un point de vue politique.
C'est c'est ça a été sa constante. Bon
et donc voilà ça ça a abouti on va dire
à la première enquête le premier livre
et pourquoi je me suis remis au sur le
dire au boulot pourquoi je me suis remis
au boulot alors ça c'est quand même
quelque chose à raconter euh parce que
il y a des journalistes qui me posent
"Mais pourquoi vous êtes obsédé par
Emmanuel Macron ?" Non je suis pas
obsédé par Emmanuel Macron mais euh le
fait est c'est que j'ai beaucoup enquêté
sur Emmanuel Macron. Donc il y a
beaucoup de choses à découvrir encore
d'une certaine manière. Et puis par
ailleurs, il est devenu président de la
République. Donc l'intérêt a augmenté,
on va dire, hein.
Est-ce que vous avez senti des écoutes
sur votre personne ?
Oui, des écoutes sur euh Oui, oui, oui,
oui, oui. Alors, ça, on peut parler, on
peut en parler.
Allez, euh et on reviendra au pourquoi
de l'enquête.
Merci.
Euh alors euh
bon, oui, oui, écoutez sûrement. En tout
cas, j'ai quelques éléments qui me qui
m'amènent à penser que je suis pas je
suis pas naïf. Les les là aussi, c'est
très difficile. Sur les sources les plus
sensibles, j'ai essayé au maximum de
sécuriser les contacts.
Comment ? Chiffrement avec une clé de
chiffrement.
Oui. Alors, non, pas forcément sur
internet, mais parce que là, je pense à
des téléphones portables que j'ai dû euh
acheter, jeter euh et encore, c'est
toujours très pénible et très très
sensible, mais toujours avec euh,
comment dire ? Euh enfin, j'ai j'ai
essayé de prendre le maximum de
précautions sur les sources les plus
sensibles.
Après après euh après, j'ai augmenté ma
sécurité
informatique qui était pas terrible, je
dois le dire au début. Enfin, en tout
cas dans
euh Non, même pas, enfin au début mais
et et après c'est pas c'est de toute
façon mes sources, c'est des sources
physiques la plupart du temps.
C'est la meilleure façon de protéger.
c'est des sources physiques. Donc c'est
pour ça que ma sécurité informatique
était était un peu en de ça. Mais par
exemple, j'ai pas écrit le livre sur mon
ordinateur connecté internet au wifi.
Bon, c'est la base mais euh il y a des
journalistes qui le font. Euh donc euh
non, euh donc j'ai été euh même par
rapport à mon éditeur, j'ai dû être un
peu parano parce que la culture de la
sécurité et dans les éditeurs français
quasi nulle comme dans les rédactions.
D'ailleurs, la culture de la sécurité
dans les rédactions est nulle. On n'est
jamais trop parano.
Oui. Donc on n'est jamais trop parano.
C'est vrai. Ben je je vais vous raconter
pourquoi. Parce qu'il y a une histoire
que j'ai jamais raconté en tant que
c'est il y a quelques révélations entre
guillemets. Donc euh et donc euh quand
je disais donc source physique, donc
parfois je suis passé par des
intermédiaires qui me permettaient de
rencontrer des gens sans qu'il y ait
contact électronique d'une manière ou
d'une autre. Le le la chose que j'ai
j'ai le fait le plus précisément, c'est
de de mettre mon mon portable dans une
cage de farad quand je rencontrais
certains interlocuteurs pour éviter
d'être pisté. Bon euh euh alors après
euh bien évidemment le problème c'est
que les sources
elles parlent aussi elles ont pas
forcément de la culture de sécurité.
Elles ont pas forcément de la la culture
de sécurité. Et le problème c'est que à
la fois par l'urgence de l'enquête par
le fait que c'est difficile de dire à
des sources ne parlez pas là parce que
ça les rend parano donc elle parle
moins. Donc le rapport à la sécurisation
aux sources sur une enquête aussi
politique que ça et une au sens
institution du terme c'est le président
de la République euh fait que c'est très
difficile d'instaurer une sécurité
maximale. Donc je sais que parfois il y
a eu il y a eu des éléments surveillés.
Alors comment je le sais ? Bah notamment
parce que alors l'Élysée a mis du temps
à comprendre que je faisais le livre ce
livre là parce que autant le premier
livre qui était une enquête qui était
déjà enquêtée mais qui était plus une
enquête politique là sur la le deuxème
livre comme l'objet du livre c'est le le
le le soubassement et la structuration
de de de d'Emmanuel Macron en fait
l'infrastructure pour faire du marxisme
on va dire je me suis pas intéressé à
superstru structure, à ses idées ou à
son jeu politique. Non, je me suis
intéressé à la République de l'ombre,
c'est au réseau de l'ombre de la 5e
République, parfois des réseaux de
financement. Je me suis intéressé à son
rapport au régalien, à l'État. Euh donc,
je me suis intéressé à la
France-Afrique, je me suis intéressé au
complexe militaire industriel parce
qu'en fait la question que je me suis
posé aussi, c'est comment ? C'est pas é
c'est pas c'est pas uniquement c'est pas
uniquement la la question que j'ai eu.
pas uniquement pourquoi a-t-il été élu
et comment il a réussi à être élu avec
tous les soutiens qu'il a pu avoir, mais
c'est comment il a pris le contrôle de
l'État qui est une machine extrêmement
complexe et ce n'est pas uniquement
parce qu'il avait des réseaux à
l'inspection générale des finances ou
qu'il avait donc des réseaux à Bercis,
mais c'est qu'il avait aussi des réseaux
et qu'il a pris des réseaux anciens et
passés parfois souvent mais place Bova
dans la défense et qu'il a récupéré et
qu'il a siphonné comme un banquier
d'affaires qui fait une opa sur une
entreprise, il a sihonné les vieux
réseaux de la République et donc sa
promesse de renouvellement et son
marketing sur c'est le nouveau monde,
c'est euh bah c'est c'est un mensonge et
honté parce qu'en réalité il n'a fait
que recycler tous les réseaux qui
étaient déjà présents. Et pour revenir à
l'idée de partie unique, mon intuition
de départ sur l'enquête, c'était que les
réseaux, ce qu'on appelle les réseaux
transversaux, d'autres journalistes ont
étudié ce qu'on appelle les réseaux
transversaux de l'ombre, notamment
Pierre Payé, la République des mallettes
2011 qui était principalement sur un
personnage qui s'appelle Alexandre
Jouri, mais c'est pas Alexandre Jour qui
est important, c'est le système autour
d'Alexandre Jouri. Qu'est-ce qu'il y a
derrière ? C'est les fameux réseaux
transversaux qui travaillent qui a qui
ont travaillé historiquement pour la
droite et la gauche française. Donc
c'est les réseaux encore une fois
France-Afrique, complexe métoire
industriel, réseau de renseignement bien
évidemment
c'est ce que certaines personnes
appellent l'état profond.
J'ai pas employé le terme d'état profond
parce que
trop connoté
parce que trop conoté parce que ça
renvoie une réalité américaine avec
Trump qui se victimise par rapport
effectivement à une réalité aussi
américaine c'est une surpuissance du
système de renseignement américain et du
complexe militaire industriel qui il
faut le rappeler est une expression
d'Asener durant la guerre froide qui
lui-même avait du mal avec son complexe
militaire industriel parce qu'il voulait
avoir de la détente par rapport au bloc
soviétique. Donc ça, on était sous la
guerre froide, mais donc aux États-Unis,
il y a quand même une situation un peu
particulière, mais j'ai pas utilisé ce
terme là d'état profond
qui est utilisé qui est utilisé par
Macron. Sauf que comme d'habitude,
Macron utilise des concepts mais à
mauvaise essence, c'estàd pour qualifier
une réalité qui ne correspond pas au
concept. Donc il il parle de il parle
d'état profond sur le Cadoris en parle
d'avant en parlant de l'administration
du Cadors et pas en parlant de ce qu'est
réellement le le le l'état profond en
tant que tel.
Et donc
et aussi par ailleurs, j'ai pas utilisé
point des terme le terme d'état profond
parce que aussi trop connoté y compris
par rapport à une réalité américaine
parce que je voulais pas me faire
accuser de complotisme par les les
certaines personnes notamment je pense
bah notamment les commentateurs. Vous
parliez de Jean-Michel Apati ou des
choses comme ça et les gens qui
reçoivent les enquêtes ensuite enfin qui
sont censés les lire. Mais le le le le
l'élément c'est que en fait je me suis
aperçu que Macron a récupéré l'état
profond et que donc pas totalement, ça a
été imparfait, ça a pu lui jouer des
tours aussi. Il y a également des des
des jeux de pouvoir extrêmement
particuliers. On va pouvoir peut-être
parler de la de la de la Sarkozy après
et et également de le de du jeu très
complexe entre Nicolas Sarkozy et
Emmanuel Macron parce que le
rapprochement entre Nicolas Sarkozy et
Emmanuel Macron et l'avantage et
s'explique d'abord et en princip
justement ce jeu complexe autour des
vieux réseaux beaucoup plus que sur un
jeu politique même s peuvent
s'instrumentaliser les deux sur le plan
politique mais en fait bon voilà ça je
je veux juste revenir sur sur votre
question de de de de tout à l'heure qui
est importante, c'est euh donc est-ce
que j'ai été surveillé ? Oui. Comment
j'en ai eu la preuve, c'est que donc euh
sur cette deuxème enquête, vu la
sensibilité de l'enquête, vu la
sensibilité de l'enquête, euh j'ai
plutôt au départ euh on va dire euh euh
undercover entre guillemets vis-à-vis
des communiquants de Macron. C'est j'ai
pas j'ai pas dit "Ah ben je fais un
livre d'ailleurs euh Oh bah c'est sur
place Bovau, c'est sur la défense, c'est
sur tout ça." Non, j'ai pas j'ai pas
expliqué ça. Donc j'ai j'ai vu beaucoup
de gens hein. Pourtant j'ai vu euh je
sais pas, j'ai pas fait le compte mais
j'ai dû voir 200 interlocuteurs, j'ai vu
des gens plusieurs fois. J'ai aussi mon
propre carnet d'adresse maintenant hein
parce que j'ai quand même fait de
l'enquête depuis 10 ans. Donc sur des
des champs de pouvoir extrêmement
différenciés, médias, politique,
économie et et tous ces secteursl. Et
donc euh donc j'ai vu des gens, j'ai pas
j'ai dit à très très peu de gens que je
faisais un livre parmi mes
interlocuteurs
euh et à un moment donné euh ils s'en
sont quand même aperçus parce que je
devais faire quand même un minimum de
contradictoire pour des raisons
juridiques notamment notamment là je
parle pas de contradictoire vis-à-vis de
de de l'État, vis-à-vis de Macron de
l'Élysée, mais de contradictoire par
rapport à certains réseaux sensibles euh
et Donc, j'ai dû interroger certaines
personnes qui là se sont aperçu que
j'enquêtais sur eux, des réseaux qui
sont d'ailleurs par ailleurs parfois
dangereux
et donc
bah qui procède de la menace pas il
passe pas à la menace mais il vous
menace
de procédure ou de se faire couler dans
du béton
euh plutôt deuxème deuxième aspect. Oui.
Euh et des gens qui sont pas très
sympathiques parfois. Euh mais euh là
c'est pareil, je veux pas me victimiser.
Donc j'en ai pas parlé jusqu'à présent
mais mais le le le en tout cas là où je
me suis aperçu qu'ils avaient quand même
quelques renseignements sur mon enquête,
c'est que euh bien évidemment par des
sources qui euh qui qui faisaient partie
de leur entourage parce que j'ai aussi
rencontré des gens très très proches
d'Emmanuel Macron. Donc à un moment
donné ça ça c'est remonté aux oreilles
de du président de la République, mais
ils ont mis quand même du temps à s'en
apercevoir parce que j'ai j'ai commencé
vraiment l'enquête à partir de mai-juin
2018. Je suis parti de Marianne en
septembre 2018. Je me suis mis à fond
sur l'enquête entre euh septembre et
janvier 2018. J'ai écrit en février
2018. J'ai fait les dernières
interviews, rencontres prises de contact
entre janvier, entre février et mars
2018. Et euh mon point de contact, on va
dire avec le château, ça a été début
mars 2018. Et euh ce point de contact,
j'allais envoyer un mail de questions
contradictoire. Donc, j'allais le faire.
C'était j'avais prévu de l'envoyer à
CBATI d'ailleurs et il y a un conseiller
qui m'a devancé, qui m'a expliqué que
ils étaient au courant. Et donc à ce
moment-là, ce n'est pas là où je me
demande si j'ai été surveillé parce que
avec toutes les sources que j'ai vu,
c'est que euh c'est la teneur de la
discussion que j'ai eu avec ce
conseiller-là qui montrait que sur
certains dossiers, ils étaient au
courant de mon enquête, notamment sur la
question d'énergie, de gaz, nucléaire,
la France-Afrique, ça les inquiétait
beaucoup, la campagne, le financement de
la campagne. C'était les cinq
thématiques qui m'ont été délivrées
comme ça pour voir ma réaction. Et donc
là, j'ai compris que ils avaient quand
même un certain niveau d'information euh
sur l'enquête. Ils avaient pas tout. Par
exemple, ils ne m'ont pas en tout cas
transmis l'information qu'ils avaient
euh que j'enquêtais sur l'Algérie qui
est un terrain très sensible dans
l'enquête. On va on va on va en on va en
parler de l'Algérie. Euh et et lors de
cet entretien, c'est un déjeuner avec
quelqu'un que je connais bien, que dont
je ter le nom parce que j'ai pas
d'éléments de preuve euh de toute
manière. Et puis bon euh je vais pas euh
euh comment dire je suis pas du genre à
Bref et donc lors de ce de déjeuner là
euh
lors de ce déjeuner là, je peux dire ça
je l'ai jamais dit mais lors de ce
déjeuner là j'ai eu des menaces. Oui. Et
euh
de quel type ? Alors de types classiques
euh j'allais dire euh et un peu bébette
parce que franchement
tu as jamais pu travailler quelque part
ou des choses comme ça.
Alors ça genre
les patrons de presse sont pas très
courageux donc euh pensez à votre
carrière. Bon, j'ai eu ça euh mais j'ai
eu droit à des menaces de contrôle
fiscal euh qui m'a été menaces qui m'ont
été qui ont été réitéré devant une
conseur
dont je terra le nom parce que c'est
quelqu'un avec qui enfin que je connais
mais qui me l'a répété. Voilà. Et euh
mais ça c'est simple, on va dire, c'est
presque lambda enfin depuis depuis
Mitteran et puis voilà. Mais j'ai eu un
j'ai eu un message un peu particulier,
exactement la phrase, la citation que
j'ai pas utilisé dans le livre, ça a été
je ne sais pas ce dont il est capable.
Un accident de vélo est si vite arrivé.
Donc ça a été répété trois fois avec le
sourire sur le ton de la plaisanterie
avec quelqu'un que je connaissais depuis
pas mal de temps. Mais quand on est sur
le ton de la plaisanterie dans ce dans
ces domaines sensibles, on n'est pas sur
le ton de la plaisanterie. Voilà, c'est
au minima une pression directe,
une un moyen de de faire pression quoi,
de d'intimider. C'est de l'intimidation.
Et d'ailleurs,
l'accident de vélo, c'est parce que tout
le monde sait que je circule à vélo à
Paris et
ça m'a été réitéré par d'autres canaux.
C'est bon, les gens peu sympathiques que
je décrivais
il y a quelques temps, enfin dans
l'interview, j'ai j'ai il y a il y a pas
que ce conseiller du président de la
République qui m'a menacé d'un inquident
de vélo, il y a plusieurs personnes au
cours de l'enquête. Donc oui, ça amène à
être un peu parano, je le suis pas
totalement, on peut pas, c'est
impossible sinon on peut pas vivre. Mais
c'est c'est et là on en revient à la
prudence des journalistes de s'attaquer
à qui ? entre guillemets de s'attaquer
hein, d'enquêter, restons factuel, au
président de la République dans le cadre
de la 5e République. Et ça, je vous le
délivre parce que par rapport aux
questions de liberté individuelle, de
violence policière, de la situation
extrêmement gravissime qu'on a dans ce
pays, il faut que les gens, il y a des
gens qui qui en sont conscients bien
évidemment, les militants, les gilets
jaunes, les internautes, mais je dois
dire et il y a également beaucoup de
gens qui connaissent le pouvoir, qui
sont même engagés parfois auprès du
président de la République, qui sont se
sont engagés dans en marche ou qui ont
fait partie des alliés politiques de
d'Emmanuel Macron qui savent bien qu'on
est que les lignes rouges ont largement
été franchies en terme de liberté
individuelle. Euh ce que les gens ont du
mal à comprendre, c'est que comme il n'y
a pas eu de cadrage euh politique et
médiatico-politique
comme sous Sarkozy où Sarkozi à la fois
devait affronter les anciens chirakiens
qui voulaient toujours se venger de
baladure et de la campagne et de la
trahison de baladure, il y a toute une
presse qui a a relayé tout un
storytelling qui était juste en plus
hein avec des vraies collusions, des
vrais des comment dire des vraies
problématiques de potentiel afférisme
voire même corruption et et compagnie.
Il y a eu des condamnations encore
récentes sur les Balcanies et compagnie.
C'est pas pour dire que Nicolas Sarkozi
est tout blanc, c'est loin de là. Et
j'ai travaillé sur la la j'ai travaillé
sur la SarkoZie. On parlait de Big
Malon, mais j'ai travaillé sur d'autres
dossiers qui concernaient la Sarkozy.
Sauf c'était moins chaud parce que il y
avait une pluralité au-delà de la
presse, il y avait une pluralité
politique et c'était et et notamment
institutionnel, je reviens en terme
institutionnel. et il y avait une
pluralité euh euh
politique et et institutionnelle qui
faisait que à la fois euh il y avait
plus de sources disponibles et surtout
c'était moins dangereux parce que euh il
y avait également euh l'institution
judiciaire qui pouvait carburer parfois.
Il y avait également euh euh il y avait
simplement les contrepouvoirs, il sont y
compris au sein même de l'État.
Sauf que maintenant avec Macron, c'est
mort. Bah en tout cas, tant
qu'aujourd'hui il n'y aura pas de
véritable concurrent,
c'est pas un jugement de valeur hein,
mais de de véritables concurrent
institutionnel, encore une fois ce n'est
pas des jugements de valeur, mais euh
qui ont une capacité d'avoir des
contacts avec l'espace de pouvoir tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui. Oui, Macron.
Alors qu'il y a un paradoxe, je parle de
château de cartes dans dans l'enquête au
niveau du résutage parce que il y a
aussi comment dire il y a un cadrage qui
ferait que Macron serait surpuissant
avec des réseaux surpuissants derrière
lui. Moi en fait, il y a des réseaux
surpuissants mais déjà c'est pas
forcément ceux auquels les gens en
croient d'une certaine manière et les
les et les les réseaux surpuissants, ils
ont leur propre ajada.
Mais les gens pensent à quoi en terme de
réseau ? Bah le truc habituel, les
oligarques, les grands patrons, les
grands patrons de presse. Euh euh euh en
réalité Macron euh moi ce qui peut
m'inquiéter euh du côté euh des grandes
forces capitalistes là pour le coup par
exemple, c'est le sa proximité euh là
sur le dossier des retraites avec Black
Rock par exemple euh euh qu'il rencontre
à plusieurs reprises en en en juillet à
partir de juin 2017.
Ce que j'explique dans dans l'enquête,
c'est que il c'est que
il a eu plutôt tendance à rencontrer
aussi pour des raisons d'imag, je suis
pas je suis pas dupe, mais il a eu
plutôt tendance à rencontrer les des
grands patrons internationaux et
notamment américains des Gafas parce que
c'est bien pour l'image, c'est bien
c'est bien pour son marketing, l'homme
neuf, ça fait June, c'est machin
compagnie mais en mais il y a quand même
une vraie appétence pour Macron pour ces
gens-là. et il a plutôt tenu à distance
le patronat traditionnel français. Pas
forcément les patrons de médias et
quoique il il y a eu des bisb depuis
2017 qui sont pas forcément
intelligibles par le grand public parce
que justement le milieu médiatique est
plus neutralisé aujourd'hui parce que je
vous ai expliqué sur le rapport aux
sources par la neutralisation politique
générale sur par la surprudence plus que
par un contrôle des des grands patrons
de médias. Il y a je pense même je suis
même quasiment sûr que certains grands
patrons de médias aimeraient plus que
leur certaines de leurs rédactions même
soient plus virulentes à l'égard de
Macron d'une certaine manière. Euh et
c'est là où les les journalistes sont
souvent ils ont deux deux gares de
retard généralement par rapport au
rapport de force y compris de pouvoir et
économique par rapport à ces euh ces
forces économiques là sur internet
connauissants
[Musique]
derrière Macron c'est quoi ? Bah moi ce
que enfin les réseaux surpuissants euh
quand j'ai dit surpuissant, c'estàd que
un je moi je mets plutôt de la distance
sur l'idée que Macron serait aujourd'hui
surpuissant. Il est puissant parce qu'il
est président de la 5e République et
qu'il a donc institutionnellement
beaucoup de pouvoir dans une République
qui est en fait consubstantiellement
très relativement autoritaire enfin qui
peut avoir une dérive autoritaire. Coup
d'état permanent Méran le livre de
Mitteran. Donc je veux dire la 5e
République n'est pas intrèquement un
régime hyper démocratique. Donc ça c'est
un élément structurel par rapport à la
puissance de de d'Emmanuel Macron. Je
dis je mettais sur puissance à la fois
en insistant et en mettant des
guillemets parce que je pense qu'on a
tendance à le rendre surpuissant aussi
par rapport à l'image qu'on peut avoir
des rapports de force y compris dans le
monde économique. On parlera de la 5G
peut-être après par exemple. Et euh euh
par ailleurs euh par ailleurs, il y a un
autre un autre élément, c'est que euh je
pense que euh et je je le sais, c'est
aussi un peu toute mon enquête euh un
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que je sur quoi
je suis tombé ? Et c'est pareil là,
j'apporte des éléments factuels. Alors,
les gens parfois disent "Ah mais non,
mais ça a pas pu se passer comme ça."
Bah si, ça s'est pu se passer comme ça.
L'élément factuel, le plus factuel,
c'est que Emmanuel Macron, malgré tout
son résutage, les fundising qu'il a eu
en 2016, en réalité commission des
comptes des campagnes, la commission des
comptes commission des comptes de
campagne, les comptes dans les comptes
déposés dans les dons déposés donc
officiellement servi officiellement à la
campagne, il en a comment dire qualifié
enfin exposé je sais plus je perd mes
mots 5 millions d'euros. C'est les 5
millions d'euros qu'il a eu à partir euh
sur euh 4600 € dont au candidat 7500 €
au parti sur toute l'année 2016. Il en a
il n'en a pas euh affirmé plus sur
l'année 2017. Les dons qu'il a reçu sur
l'année 2017 sont passés par le parti
mais ils ont pas été déposés à la
commission des comptes de campagne sur
la campagne parce que en réalité il a
réussi à boucler les comptes de les
comptes de campagne qu'il a déposé à
partir des pr
des comptes de campagne à l'époque
bah c'est plusieurs personnes puis il y
a toujours eu des il y a toujours des
experts comptables. Après, il y a le
trésorier, c'est Cédric Havait
l'équipe financière était plus complexe
que Cédric Ha en fait. Il y a il y a
différentes personnes.
Fait perdre votre fil.
Ouais. Et donc là, c'est très très
important à comprendre parce qu'en fait
il y a un trou noir dans la campagne
entre janvier et avril 2017 où en fait
la campagne a eu des problèmes de
trésorerie. Pourquoi ? Parce que ce
n'est que en avril 2017 qu'Emmanuel
Macron a réussi à avoir des prêts
bancaires.
Pourquoi ? parce que il n'avait pas de
parti politique constitué avec des fonds
propres, des bâtiments et autres. Et
notamment depuis l'affaire Big Malon,
les banques sont extrêmement prudente à
prêter au responsable politique, même
quand il s'appelle Emmanuel Macron. Et
les deux banques qui ont prêté
finalement à Emmanuel Macron, donc
notamment dans mon souvenir Crédit
Mutuel et et la BRED Banque Populaire,
Natix 6, enfin
le CIC.
Oui, enfin c'est pas passé par le CIS,
mais je pense que oui, c'est le même
groupe. Euh
alors, pourquoi Crédit Mutuel dans mon
souvenir ? Là, il faut pas que je me je
me trompe, mais c'est parce que ils
avaient un compte à Sherchield
euh et la BRED à l'époque qui était
dirigée par François Perol, ancien
secrétaire général adjoint de Nicolas
Sarkozi. Tiens donc. Mais c'est donc
c'était deux ban c'était deux banques
plutôt amis de l'écosystème Rotschield.
Et ces ces prêts-là n'ont été obtenus
que en toute fin et en dernière ligne
droite de la campagne. Et pourquoi ?
Parce que euh Macron a eu beaucoup de
mal à s'assurer. C'est-à-dire que à
trouver une assurance qui voulait bien
assurer les prêts. Finalement, ça a été
Alliance, exagf repris par les
Allemands. Et comment il a pu être
assuré ? Grâce à une société de courtage
qui s'appelle Cassie Saint-Honoré qui
est dirigé par Pierre Donasberg. Euh or
à l'époque euh le groupe qui dirigeait
Cass Saint enfin qui était propriétaire,
ils l'ont revendu, c'est Cassis
Saint-Honoré. Euh il y avait bon euh la
boîte Edmond Rothschield qui a a
différencié de de la banque Rothschield.
C'est deux groupes différents. C'est
deux branches de la famille qui se sont
fait la guerre économique d'ailleurs.
Mais surtout Cassis Saint-Honoré
appartenait à l'époque à un groupe d' un
fond d'investissement qui s'appelle le
fond Ardient qu'on retrouve d'ailleurs
sur les affaires des aéroports à
Toulouse et sur ADP.
Et donc sépare l'action de Pierre
Donasberg qui d'ailleurs a fait une
partie de sa fortune sur l'assurance du
système nucléaire français
EDF et Areva parce que là c'est pareil
c'est des secteurs difficilement on peut
le comprendre par rapport au risques
technologiques qui peuvent être
difficilement assurés et donc Cassis
Saint-Honoré qui est une société de
courtage joue les intermédiaires avec
les assurances pour servir de tampon en
terme de de prise de risque jurque.
juridique notamment et c'est eux qui ont
permis à Macron finalement d'obtenir
d'obtenir les prêts. Alors pourquoi ça
d'autres implications ? Je vais pas
dévoiler d'autres éléments que j'ai pas
pour l'instant dévoilé mais j'ai
d'autres informations qui sont très
concordantes avec ce que j'ai pu
raconter dans dans le livre par rapport
à cet élément-là. Et par ailleurs, il y
a un trou noir de 4 mois, 5 mois de de
problèmes de trésorerie sur la campagne.
Ce qui explique d'ailleurs, ça je l'ai
expliqué dans l'OPS quand quand j'ai
sorti le livre, euh c'est que euh ça
explique aussi pourquoi il y a certains
prestataires qui ont sous-facturé.
Ça a été ça a été dit par la presse en
2018, Média Part, Radio France, le la
cellule d'investigation effectivement
avait pointé que la une partie des
prestataires avait surfacturé
sous-facturé et pas surfacturé avait
sous-facturé les prestations
mais voilà parce que il y avait des
vrais problèmes des des vrais problèmes
de de de trésorerie sur la campagne de
Macron. Exemple que je cite dans le
livre qui est totalement prouvé.
Emmanuel Macron pour les tractes de la
campagne a utilisé l'imprimeur
historique du Parti socialiste qui
faisait les tractes également pour
Benoît Amont pour le Parti socialiste.
La l'avance historique enfin habituelle
de cet imprimeur à chaque campagne
électorale pour chaque candidat
socialiste notamment à la présidentielle
était de l'ordre de 1 million d'euros.
Et Macron, il a pas il a pas eu d'avance
à payer
après négociation. Alors ça, on peut les
retrouver sur le sur les Macron Lex
parce qu'il y a des échanges de mail
entre justement les équipes financières
de Macron et l'imprimeur. Oui. Question
d'internet, Macron est-il réellement en
train de renvoyer l'ascenseur à ceux qui
l'ont fait élire où il croit clairement
à ce véhicule comme programme ou les
deux ? Est-ce que Est-ce qu'il a
Alors euh je vais répondre mais j'ai pas
encore répondu sur les surpuissances
mais en fait continue sur les
surpuissances.
Voilà, on va continuer sur puissance et
après je réponds à la à la à la
question. Donc euh donc je dis plusieurs
choses. Je crois que j'ai déjà dit que
ça servait à rien de de le rendre sur
plus puissant qu'il naît parce qu'en
fait il est de mon point de vue plus
fragile qu'on peut le croire et donc il
faut tout le discours de il est
surpuissant et c'est pas c'est pas
politiquement je pense et puis en terme
de citoyenneté enfin c'est des mots
valises un peu mais un peu gal
malheureusement galvodé mais ce que je
veux dire c'est c'est c'est pas comme ça
que comment dire qu'on peut avancer dans
la compréhension d'Emmanuel Macron
Après, quand je dis surpuissance, c'est
que oui, il a utilisé des réseaux qui
sont bien plus puissants et enfin de mon
point de vue beaucoup moins connu du
grand public et qui là pour le coup peut
lui demander des retours, on va dire, à
l'envoyeur beaucoup plus discret mais
beaucoup plus stratégique dans le
domaine de l'énergie dans le domaine et
donc là on retrouve,
on va dire le domaine de l'énergie
nucléaire mais Ktinski, le gaz, enfin je
fais pas de liaison entre tout ça, même
si je parle de Kétinski dans l'enquête
parce que effectivement je me aperçu
qu'il faisait du lobbing auprès de la
Macronie et et en utilisant notamment
des anciens réseaux de la droite et que
ça fonctionnait plutôt pas mal. Euh
sans doute pas que lui qui doit faire du
lobbing.
Non. Et mais dans ces milieux-là peu
médiatisés hein, le domaine de
l'énergie, c'est quasiment quasiment pas
couvert par la presse. Il y a un
rebricard au monde qui fait plutôt
honnêtement son travail. Il y a parfois
des articles de Martine Orange sur Media
Part mais enfin globalement sur
l'énergie
en dehors de la presse économique type
les échos. Là pour le coup, ils font
enfin ils font il relait de la
communication des groupes. Euh si je
fais de l'autopromo pour un un journal
qui qui a bien voulu me faire travailler
ces dernières semaines et ces derniers
mois c'est le la tribune qui existe
toujours euh et qui m'a permis de faire
la quatre pages d'enquête assz assz
assez fouillé sur sur EDF et sur Hercule
et euh les projets de de relance du
nucléaire. Euh et euh et donc c'est plus
dans ces domaines stratégiques-là où
potentiellement il y a peut il peut y
avoir des collusions parce que c'est des
domaines stratégiques où l'État a encore
son mot à dire clairement et euh et et
là il peut y avoir collusion et
d'ailleurs ça a été un peu toute
l'enquête que j'ai que j'ai mené c'est
que j'ai montré qu'il y avait des
interconnexions très fortes avec ces
gens-là qui on pour l'instant ont été
peu médiatisés et pourquoi parce que
c'est aussi des réseaux là les fameux
réseaux transversaux dont on parle
beaucoup moins dans la République
française. que y compris aujourd'hui les
grands patrons qui ont eu leur
comment dire leur leur influence d'une
certaine manière par le résotage, par la
caisse de résonance et compagnie. Sauf
que il y a quand même un fait quand je
disais que Macron avait mis plutôt à
l'écart le le vieux CAC 40,
c'est aussi parce que une partie du
vieux CAC 40, parce qu'on parle beaucoup
de Xavinial ou de Bernard Arnaud, mais
une partie du K40 avait soutenu Fillon
jusqu'au bout et qui est resté jusqu'au
bout. Ce qui explique d'ailleurs les
problèmes assurentiels de Macron, hein,
parce que il faut il faut se rappeler
que Henry Decast était directeur
général, enfin même s'il il s'était mis
en congé de de du groupe AXA. Donc euh
euh en fait une partie du CAC 40
soutenait Fillon comme ils ont soutenu
Ain GUP. Ils voulaient la droite hein au
départ hein, enfin la droite la droite
affirmée comme telle. Euh euh on l'a un
peu oublié donc c'est facile de refaire
l'histoire après coup.
J'ouvre une parenthèse.
Ouais.
Durant ça, est-ce que vous avez pensé
contre vous-même ?
en se disant voilà bon bah c'est
l'appareil d'état, il y a beaucoup de
cercles d'influence, ça se croise, ça se
recroise mais bon, ils ont peut-être
rien à voir entre eux.
Ah mais oui. Alors
je me fais la vocal.
Non non mais vous avez raison, vous avez
raison. C'est J'allais en parler tout à
l'heure. C'est pas parce que on met
trois points euh et qu'on trace un trait
que il y a il y a une vraie histoire.
Et c'est pas parce que il y a quatre
points, quatre personnes qui se
connaissent
qui a vraie histoire. Alors, un des
reproches sur le livre, il y en a pas eu
beaucoup en fait, mais là je parle des
confrères, ça a été Ah mais il y a
beaucoup de N dropping en gros bah c'est
un livre sur les réseaux. Donc à un
moment donné, si on cite pas les noms, y
compris de gens. Alors pourquoi ils
disent ça les journalistes ? C'est parce
que il y a beaucoup de gens qui sont pas
connus donc ils en font quoi ? parce
qu'ils savent pas eux-mêmes qui c'est en
fait et c'est aussi le problème. Et donc
quand j'explique par exemple, je sais
pas moi quand enfin quand j'explique par
exemple quand je parle d'Alexandre Jouri
à un moment donné et que je parle que
j'explique j'expose que Alexandre Jouri
et a eu des affaires avec un homme
d'affaires irlandais qui s'appelle
Thomas Francis Glison. Bon, qui ça ça
sur la place de Paris au niveau des
enquêteurs ? Une dizaine, une vingtaine
au mieux euh au niveau des initiés,
peut-être une centaine de personnes,
mais pas euh pas les journalistes de la
grande majorité, ils savent même pas qui
c'est Thomas Francis Gison. Alors que
c'est un élément clé du réseau
d'Alexandre Jouri dans et dans sa
structuration de réseau depuis plus de
20 ans.
Donc mais là ça bon mais et donc pour
revenir à
à la question, oui, c'est pas parce que
il y a quatre points, même quand ils
sont en lien que il y a eu une histoire
euh
effectivement, mais sauf que quand je
fais parfois du dropping dans le livre,
c'est que j'ai l'histoire parfois mais
que je ne peux pas la que je ne peux pas
la raconter parce que je n'ai pas les
preuves.
Ça c'est important. C'estàd que j'ai
l'histoire mais j'ai pas pu la raconter
totalement en entier parce que j'ai pas
les preuves et je sais que c'est vrai,
c'est recoupé entièrement mais il faut
des preuves et là parce que là je
m'expose à des gens qui peuvent euh
totalement m'attaquer et qui peuvent me
détruire d'une certaine manière. Euh et
donc parfois j'ai fait du dropping euh
euh
alors je sais exactement ce qui s'est
passé parfois sur certains sujets euh
mais je je suis resté prudent à la fois
pour des raisons euh euh de preuve mais
aussi des raisons euh euh de sécurité et
et sauf que parfois j'ai j'ai et quand
j'ai dévoilé des concordances de
réseaux, je pense notamment à des
réseaux autour d'ADP par exemple de la
privatisation d'ADP euh qui revient à la
caisse des dépôts
Euh et bien euh je je je pense que enfin
c'est c'est pas je pense, je sais euh
qu'il y a pas de hasard. Voilà, il y a
pas de hasard et et d'ailleurs
j'explique en partie hein quand je dis
j'explique pas en fait dans le livre,
j'explique beaucoup de choses.
Rappelez-moi le nom du livre.
Euh le grand manipulateur, bon ça c'est
le titre de l'éditeur, il voulait un
truc un peu un peu psychologisant et un
peu clivant. Enfin clivant légèrement,
mais enfin le grand manipulateur et les
réseaux secrets de Macron. Voilà. Non,
ça c'est ça c'est le c'est le bouquin.
Mais mais mais
sur la question les quatre points
alignés, c'est pas parce que il y a
quatre points que on peut faire le
trait, il faut avoir l'histoire et euh
et voilà. Et donc ça c'est pour répondre
à plein de gens. Je donne un un un un
exemple très concret et qui qui apparaît
comme une lapalissade. Mais donc les
gens euh
enfin les gens je dis les gens enfin le
public ou pas le public mais ils disent
même des confrères.
Ah mais Macron c'est c'est Alain Mc
Atalie. Mais ça déjà c'est le haut de
l'iceberg. Et puis en plus ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est qu'ils sont pas en contact
réel aujourd'hui avec le président de la
République en réelle influence à la main
un tout petit peu plus parce qu'il a un
peu plus un peu moins il a un peu moins
d'ego mais Jacques Atali en réalité ne
l'est plus du tout en contact le
président il est fâché les deux sont
fâchés ensemble je raconte une un
épisode que je n'avais pas relaté dans
le premier livre de peur de me faire
instrumentaliser notamment c'était que
Macron m'avait qualifié à Talie de
pipoter devant moi quand je l'avais
rencontré parce que je l'ai rencontré
après plusieurs reprises sur le premier
première enquête et euh et c'était en à
l'été 2015, c'était très tôt et je
m'étais demandé alors pourquoi il me le
traite de pipoder parce que il veut
mettre de la distance justement en terme
d'image. Il veut pas montrer sa
proximité. Oui, Atali a eu un rôle à
travers la commission Athalie, sa
proximité avec François Hollande
c'est grâce à Athalie et pas par
Jean-Pierre Jouillet, même si
Jean-Pierre Jouillet aura un très grand
rôle, mais c'est par Athalie que Macron
rencontre Hollande par exemple.
Et ce que je raconte, c'est même
Brigitte Macron qui connaissait Atali
d'une manière plus ancienne et qui lui
aurait demandé de présenter son mari à
François Hollande. Ça c'est pour
l'anecdote. Mais Jacques Atali depuis
2015, il a choisi son camp et son camp
ça avait été le camp de Manuel Vals.
Donc l'ennemi entre guillemets politique
à l'époque, je parle pas d'idéologie
parce que il y avait des choses qui se
rapprochent mais euh à l'époque en terme
de pouvoir de structuration de pouvoir
Atali son camp. Je cite à la main qu'à
un moment donné dans le dans le livre
dans le poche, je suis désolé de citer
pour être précis mais euh dans le poche,
j'actualise, je fais toute la campagne
présidentielle parce que je l'avais
suivi entre guillemets comme journaliste
politique et donc je fais les coulisses
dans le de aussi de la campagne dans
dans dans la dans l'actualisation de
l'enquête. Et dans l'actualisation de
l'enquête, je cite Alain Mc qui dit qui
disait à tout le monde à l'époque euh
"Macron, c'est euh c'est un génie ou euh
je sais plus la phrase mais euh euh ou
un fou euh de se lancer à la
présidentielle des 2017. Pourquoi ?
Parce que M comme Atali entre qui se
présente comme des faiseurs de roi, tout
ça c'est ça fait partie de leur
business. C'est pour arnaquer entre
guillemets en partie. Non, ça va être
diffamatoire. Donc c'est pour faire leur
business vis-à-vis de leur réseau
économique
qu'ils ont intérêt à dire qu'ils ont des
proximités avec les plus hautes
fonctions de l'État. Ça fait c'est c'est
vieux comme le monde. Mais MIN lui
défendait Jupé et ne croyait pas à
Macron en 2017. En fait, il l'avait il
avait il l'avait prépositionné pour 2022
ces gens-là. Et c'est ça que les les les
les les les
gens doivent comprendre. Il y a une
partie des gens qui ont aidé Macron, ils
avaient fait son plan de carrière, sauf
que Macron a été plus vite queeux. Donc
là ça ça c'est voilà. Et sur Atali, il
était du côté de Vals. Et ça, dans la
compréhension de la Macronis, il y a
bien quelque chose qu'il qu'il fallait
pas faire, c'était euh euh d'être du
côté de du d'être du côté de Vals.
Alors, on va pas raconter tout le
bouquin.
Non, on va pas raconter tout le bouquin.
J'aimerais qu'on parle de l'Algérie
et on va revenir sur les réseaux plus
sensibles. Euh euh, j'essaie de me
souvenir si j'ai j'ai répondu à toutes
les questions. Euh
bon, il y aura il y aura peut-être des
il y a peut-être des oublis euh mais
donc juste alors l'Algérie alors
justement c'est bien parce que Macron
a eu des problèmes d'argent sur sa
campagne et que Macron n'a pas été
entièrement aux mains des grands
capitaines d'industrie propriétaires de
presse en réalité que il est passé par
d'autres réseaux par ailleurs.
Et donc euh il a rencontré beaucoup de
gens mais y compris des gens qu'il
n'aurait pas dû rencontrer. Et donc je
fais tout je relate tout tout l'épisode
algérien où il rencontre euh des grands
patrons algériens en pleine campagne,
c'est en février 2017 et il rencontre
notamment Ali Hadad qui est le grand
patron des qui est le patron des patrons
algériens. Et tous ces gens-là en partie
sont liés à l'ancien régime. Si je vais
à toute vitesse à Bouteflica et à son
frère Saï Bouteflika. Euh mais c'est des
gens euh on va dire qui si je suis euh
euh dans l'euphémisme qui respirent pas
la première fraîcheur. Euh et donc euh
et qu'est-ce que j'ai démontré ? C'est
que il y a certains réseaux d'affaires
franco-algériens que Alexandre Benala
connaissait alors qu'il était d'origine
marocaine. Et donc l'affaire Benala n'a
pas uniquement une explication sur les
contrats russes ou une explication par
rapport à ses réseaux au Maroc, il a une
explication par rapport également à ses
contacts franco-algériens. Et c'est
c'est c'est tout ce que j'explique au
début au début du livre. Mais il y a
également d'autres éléments qui entrent
en ligne de compte. Quand je parlais
d'Alexandre Jouri, donc
très prudemment, je dis que Alexandre
Joury a peut-être rencontré euh euh
Emmanuel Macron lors de ce voyage de
février 2017. Euh je je interrogé
Alexandre Jourry qui à l'époque euh dans
un premier temps m'avait apposé silence,
dans un deuxième temps m'avait dit euh
en gros c'est pas vrai. Bon, finalement
dans un livre de de mes confrères du
monde Joan Tilwin et Simon Piel dans ce
livre là où Jy se confie à eux en
partie, ça s'appelle Ferist ce livre,
dans ce livre là, Jury dit au contraire
qu'il a bien vu Emmanuel Macron, donc il
a trois versions en un an. Bon, dans ce
livre là, il est plutôt en partie
présenté comme un un baratineur. C'est
vrai que Jy dit beaucoup de choses. Il
il fait comme Atalie, il fait comme M.
Euh, désolé pour la comparaison mais euh
enfin de toute façon euh enfin bref euh
Jy c'est un élément d'un système encore
une fois et tout ça. Il y a pas de il y
a pas d'eau probe à voir d'une certaine
manière. Il y a pas de choses qui
seraient plus radioactif que d'autres.
Enfin si d'une certaine manière mais bon
et donc euh euh
qu'est-ce que je voulais dire par
rapport à ça ? C'est que donc sur il est
présenté comme un baratineur mais en
fait il ne baratine pas totalement
parfois. Mais je dis pas que c'est vrai
là, je dis simplement que moi il m'a dit
moi j'ai des informations concordantes
qui montrent qu'il y a eu une rencontre.
Bon euh d'ailleurs, je n'en tire pas de
conclusion. Je dis simplement que s'il y
a eu ça pourrait faire mauvais effet et
que par ailleurs, ce n'est pas correct
du point de vue d'un futur président de
la République de rencontrer quelqu'un
comme Alexandre Jour, un intermédiaire
au cours de la campagne présidentielle.
Mais euh mais je pense que dans ce
dossier-là d'ailleurs qui est complexe,
je pense que d'ailleurs J a beaucoup
d'informations,
mais euh je suis pas sûr que lui-même
était opérationnel s'il y a eu
opération. Euh mais euh ce que je sais,
c'est qu'il sait beaucoup de choses. Et
il sait beaucoup de choses parce qu'il
est en contact de gens qui ont également
joué un rôle dans toute cette dans toute
cette histoire. Voilà. Et par exemple,
il y a tout un storytelling du côté de
la Macronie pour dire euh on est contre
les vieux réseaux justement, je suis
l'homme neuf et je suis contre les vieux
réseaux, y compris de la France-Afrique.
Je ne suis pas de la diplomatie des
intermédiaires. C'est ce que l'Élysée a
expliqué quand Alexandre Benala euh
s'est retrouvé au Tchad 2 de semaines 3
semaines avant le le président de la
République. Euh visite au chat
d'ailleurs. Bon bref, ça c'est un autre
sujet, on va pas l'aborder parce que
mais le soutien de la France a débit et
bon bref pose plein de questions. Mais
le le le
au moment de la vie du Tchad, l'Élysée a
expliqué d'ailleurs je je le je les cite
hein dans dans dans
a expliqué
on a rien à faire avec le business de
Benala peut-être là cette occasion là.
Oui sûrement mais nous on n plus de la
République des intermédiaires. Ce
temps-là est fini. Donc ça c'est le
storytelling général de dire tous les
affairistes ils étaient liés à Sarkozi.
Ça c'est du simplisme. Les afféristes,
ils sont dans la République et ils sont
partout et ils ont un pouvoir de
corruption important de ces affairistes.
Et là, je parle pas des grands patrons,
là je parle des affairistes, des
intermédiaires, de la France-afrique ce
qu'on parle du complexe militaire
industriel d'enjeux financiers
extrêmement importants avec énormément
d'intermédiaires. les grands les grands
contrats avec les grands les grands
scandales notamment Sawari Sarif Karashi
c'est ces grands scandales là ils ont
éclaté parce qu'il y avait à l'époque en
partie une situation politique que
j'exposé tout à l'heure qui était que
les Balardiens avaient on va dire
avaient essayé de choper la victoire à
Chiraak et que les réseaux chirakins en
fait gaulistes voulaient se venger parce
que c'était historiquement les gaulistes
qui avaient en partie avec après il y a
un partage avec on va dire la mitérandie
en partie le contrôle du complexe mit
industriel et Et donc ils ont voulu se
venger et donc il y a des gens qui ont
parlé et donc ça a permis de faire des
articles et à la justice d'incriminé.
Mais en réalité, les choses sont
beaucoup plus complexes. Il y aurait pas
une sarcosie qui serait toute noire et
tout le reste de la vie politique
française qui serait toute blanche. Non,
ça fonctionne pas comme ça. Ça ne
fonctionne pas comme ça. Et donc je suis
désolé de le dire mais voilà. Mais
est-ce que le le Non, mais je m'énerve
un peu mais mais c'est que euh c'est que
c'est que encore aujourd'hui, il y a des
gens qui enfin là des gens du pouvoir et
là je parle pas de la Macronie, je pense
par exemple à à des à des des gens qui
sont pourtant engagés en politique, aux
Parti socialistes depuis très longtemps
et qui pour certains ont tellement peu
été en contact avec ces réseaux-là, ils
ne les connaissent pas et donc ils
n'imaginent pas que ça puisse exister.
Et donc à la fois par
surprudence de leur part, peut-être
petite lâcheté et puis volonté de
regarder ailleurs, il ils n'ont même pas
la connaissance de ces réseaux-là. Donc,
ils peuvent même pas eux-mêmes en entre
guillemets en profiter pas pour
eux-mêmes mais euh par rapport par pour
critiquer leur adversaire politique.
C'est pour ça qu'on a parlé de la garder
des droite euh pour tous ces dossiers-là
de scandale. Mais je je reviens sur un
un élément euh important euh mais là
j'ai on parlait de quoi là ? Il faut
m'aider parce que j'ai j'ai perdu les
réseaux d'influence en Algérie.
Oui. Euh donc
euh
mais j'ai oublié mon idée. J'ai calé. Je
reviens je reviens je reviens à je
reviens à à voilà à Sarkozy
Sarkozy Macron et au storytelling de la
macron dire mais nous on a rien à faire
avec ces gens-là. Bon vous me demandiez
est-ce que j'ai pensé contre moi-même ?
Je vais je vais expliquer un je vais
expliquer un moment de l'enquête. Un
moment de l'enquête. Au moment où
l'affaire Benala sort dans le monde par
l'article d'Arien de chemin
et bien donc on a vu l'état de
sidération dans l'état enfin en tout cas
du côté du pouvoir ils ont mis plus de 5
jours à réagir. Il y a l'épisode
totalement recambolesque de la maison de
l'Amérique latine.
Qu'il viennent me chercher. Alexandre
Benala n'est pas mon amant. Euh enfin
des choses mais totalement délirantes
quoi, ubesque. On aurait été sous la
SarkoZie avec toute la presse qui euh
qui disait que Sarkozy était fou et que
parce que on a quand même eu ça pendant
plus de 10 ans. Je je vais me faire
passer pour un sarcosiste. Mais euh euh
voilà, on n pas eu 5 % de là. Bon,
passons.
Non, mais c'est c'est c'est tellement
sidérant que bon euh bon, le monde donc
a fait des enquêtes énormément de
papiers sur ça pendant 2 mois. On lui a
reproché ça d'ailleurs. Ils ont eu
raison de mon point de vue parce que
effectivement il y a des éléments très
interrogants qui amènent à penser que si
c'est pas la place de la contreescarpe
qui est importante en tant que tel, même
si Alexandre Benala est fautif d'une
certaine manière derrière Alexandre
Benala c'est c'est les réseaux qu'il y a
derrière c'est les c'est les c'est c'est
l'histoire qui a pu se dérouler
notamment pendant la campagne
présidentielle et donc si raison si
affaires d'état il y a c'est plutôt de
ce côté-là bon et les durant l'été
silence
Enfin pendant 5 jours, silence radio du
côté de l'Élysée, c'est la panique
totale.
Les les les habitués des plateau du côté
de la Macronie sont en manque d'éléments
de langage. Donc ils viennent pas sur
les plateaux. Enfin, tout le monde est
gêné aux entournurs. Donc il y a il y a
un gros malaise à ce moment-là. Euh et
et
mince, j'ai oublié l'idée. Je commence à
fatiguer. Et donc il y a il y a un gros
malaise à ce moment-là. Et euh voilà, je
vais j'ai retrouvé l'idée. Il y a un
gros malaise à ce momentl. Bo un coup,
bois un coup à gauche. Ouais.
Tu veux un bonbon ?
Non, c'est bon.
Ve bien un bonbon. Donc, il y a un gros
malaise à ce moment-là parce que euh il
y a un bruit qui parcourt la Macronie,
bruit que je relate dans dans l'enquête
parce que je dis euh la Macronie est
prise de la théorie du complot euh parce
que euh il pense que euh le le le alors
il pense deux choses. Il pense que le
monde a été abreuvé, que c'est une fuite
et que la fuite vient d'une certaine
personne. La personne est Bernard
Squarcini, l'ancien directeur du
renseignement intérieur sous Nicolas
Sarkozy qui faisait partie de les
équipes de l'ombre de Nicolas Sarkozy
qui a pu,
on va dire d'une manière indirecte, mais
quand même ses services ont pu
espionner, en dire, les les journalistes
à l'époque en récupérant les fadettes,
c'est le les numéros de téléphone que
les journalistes
que le journaliste appelaient. Bon, ça
c'est passé enfin il y a des tout des
affaires judiciaires en cours toujours.
Et donc la la le la rumeur dans la
macronie, enfin la macronie en fait
macronie du pouvoir là on est au niveau
de l'Élysée, c'est c'était que c'est que
l'article comme alors c'est là où il y a
il y a peut-être une nuance à voir mais
que tout ça était un coup de Bernard
Scorcini et de la SarkoZie de l'ombre
contre le chef de l'État contre Emmanuel
Macron et et donc moi-même je dois dire
le le quand l'article sort du monde sur
la place de la contreescarpe. Je me dis
mais en gros d'où ça sort ? Et à
l'époque,
Alexandre Jouri était déjà arrêté à
Londres depuis plus de 6 mois. Et donc
il y a pas mal de gens qui se sont posés
des questions à ce moment-là sur une
instrumentalisation
de de la des événements de la place de
la contreescarpe par rapport à Benala
dans un jeu de pouvoir entre la SarkoZie
et la Macronie.
Alors, sauf que bah ça ça a pas matché
au niveau de l'enquête. C'estàd que je
n'ai pas abouti à cette histoire là.
C'est pour ça que je parle de complot
dans le livre. Pourquoi ? Parce que il y
a il y a eu un autre storytelling qui a
été le storytelling, c'est un coup de la
préfecture de police et des et des
policiers contre Benala. Ça c'est une
lecture policière qui a dû jouer
d'ailleurs parce que effectivement
Benala s'est fait beaucoup d'ennemis
dans l'État et y compris du côté des
services de police et notamment la
préfecture de police. Et peut-être qu'il
y a aussi euh une prise en compte à
avoir de cet élément-là. Sauf que un euh
l'élément policier ne suffit pas enfin
euh du du de la bisbe policière ne
suffit pas à comprendre la sensibilité
du sujet autour de l'affaire Benala à
l'époque. Je parle pas d'Alexandre
Benala hein de l'affaire Benala euh
parce qu'on les communiquant ont fait de
la communication de crise ensuite
notamment à l'Élysée. Ils ont très bien
ça a très bien marché et Benala faut
dire il a apporté de l'eau au moulin.
C'est-à-dire que on a focalisé
l'attention médiatique sur Benala.
Mais on n pas regardé autour ou très
peu. Alors, on a parlé des contrats
russes effectivement qui posent des
questions de de sécurité présidentielle,
de d'intégrité de l'État, d'influence
extérieure, enfin qui pose des graves
questions de sécurité nationale. Mais en
réalité, il y a d'autres questions qui
posent des questions de sécurité
nationale dans le dossier. C'est ce que
je raconte dans le livre. Et par
ailleurs euh à l'époque donc il y a
toute la petite musique sur c'est un
coup de Scarcini, c'est un coup de
Squarini. En fait, ce dont je me suis
aperçu, c'est plusieurs choses. Bon,
certes, Scorini fait partie de la
Macronie reste quand même et a des
ennuis judiciaires. Bon, mais il y a une
partie, une grande majorité des amis de
Bernard Scarcini ou des gens qui avec
qui il est en contact euh qui ont
soutenu plus ou moins euh l'arrivée de
Macron au pouvoir.
Au niveau des réseaux polices,
il y a quand même l'ancien chef du
conseil
national du renseignement CNR, Angini,
qui a conseillé Macron pendant la
campagne. Certes, de manière ponctuelle,
mais ils sont en contact et ils se
connaissait depuis 2013 quand Macron
était à l'Élysée. Il y a un autre
policier qui est entre les réseaux de
droite et les réseaux de gauche, mais
qui qui a travaillé avec la SarkoZi
comme a travaillé avec les réseaux Jox.
Ça c'est très important. On en a pas
parlé des réseaux Jox. Donc ancien
ministre de l'intérieur de Miterran,
ancien ministre de la défense de
Mitterran et c'est une puissance en soi
les réseaux JS parce que c'est pas que
des réseaux politiques, c'est devenu
également des réseaux économique parce
que le directeur de cabinet de monsieur
JX grande figure morale de la gauche,
n'est autre que François Rousli qui est
devenu ensuite euh alors il a été
directeur de la police nationale et
surtout il est devenu ensuite patron de
DF. On revient à le nucléaire.
Et ça c'est des puissances en soi. et le
le le donc je reviens à Squarini, cette
histoire là, cette rumeur
euh
et en fait
je n'arrive pas à trouver l'histoire, à
confirmer le truc déjà et d'une bon puis
deux, ce n'est pas cohérent avec
d'autres acteurs qui entrent en dans
l'ombre en jeu soit autour de la
Ferbala, soit plus globalement autour de
la campagne et de contact avec d'autres
membres de l'équipe de Macron. Euh et
donc en réalité euh
il y avait même pas un intérêt de mon
point de vue, après peut-être que je me
trompe, mais il y avait même pas un
intérêt de Scarcini lui-même, de la
SarkoZie peut-être avoir et encore
euh à à à créer le scandale si c'est
s'il y avait un complot derrière. Mais
derrière sur tout ça, euh moi les les
les quelques sources qui m'ont ambiancé
sur ça venaient de la Macronie
et pour le coup de sources dites
autorisées à l'Élysée
qui savait que je connaissais quand même
tous ces sujets-là parce que si moi
auparavant j'avais fait quatre pages
cinq pages sur sur Jourry dans dans
Marianne et puis je connais bien le
dossier
et et donc qui m'en parlait assez
librement et qui voulait m'amener sur la
thèse d'un complot sarcoziste. Il y a
même quelqu'un qui m'a dit "Ah mais
c'est bien comme ça, on va pouvoir se
victimiser vis-à-vis de la SarkoZie."
C'est transparent là pour le coup
l'instrumentalisation, elle est directe
et parce que par rapport aux amis de de
Bernard Scarcini, enfin aux amis larges,
on peut s'interroger sur l'écosystème
autour de valeur actuelle. Par exemple,
je parlais de Charles Villeneu du groupe
Fourtou, des gens qu'on a retrouvé
d'ailleurs autour de Benala à l'automne
2000 à l'automne 2018. et on a tout le
monde a dit "Ah mais ils sont arrivés
après mais et bon il y avait quand même
quelques points de contact avant de
toute manière." Et puis par ailleurs
parce que ça là on est encore un peu sur
la surface des choses. Je suis désolé
parce que il faudrait des heures et des
heures pour raconter beaucoup de choses
et puis il y a le livre mais c'est que
en fait euh l'élément le plus moi qui
m'a le plus interpellé c'est que par
exemple quelqu'un qui
a le même avocat fiscaliste, je vais
rester très factuel pour pas pour pas
avoir de diffamation qui a le même
avocat fiscaliste où à Genève qui
s'appelle Christian Fichel ou Fel, je
sais pas comment on le dit.
Euh donc à Genève,
tout ça c'est sourcé provenu.
Oui, c'est sourcé. C'est même dans une
enquête judiciaire. C'est Areva
d'ailleurs qui qui montre ça. C'est dans
l'enquête sur Areva qui qui qu'on est
remonté sur ça, que les policiers sont
remontés sur ça. Alexandre Jouri partage
le même avocat fiscaliste à Genève que
une femme d'affaires qui s'appelle
Pascal Perez. Pascal Perez, je l'évoque
dans le livre assez longuement parce que
Pascal Perez euh ce que j'ai réussi à
démontrer, c'est que euh elle n elle
n'était pas en contact avec Benala
directement par Benala parce qu'on a
voulu faire de tous ces réseaux-là le
point de contact uniquement de Benala.
Donc ça serait Benala qui serait le
méchant avec tous les réseaux méchants
et la Macroni qui serait toute pure.
Mais non mais Pascal Perz, qu'est-ce que
je réussis à démontrer ? Qu'elle était
en contact depuis très longtemps avec un
autre homme de l'ombre. dont on a pas
pour l'instant parlé mais qui est la
personne qui était directeur des
opérations pendant la campagne
présidentielle de Macron et qui est la
personne qui a embauché Alexandre Benala
pendant la campagne enfin juste avant la
campagne. Je parlais de Ludovic Chaker
qui a un conseiller de l'ombre
d'Emmanuel Macron qui est toujours
chargé de mission à l'Élysée toujours
auprès de l'étatmajor en particulier
sauf si mes informations ne sont pas
actualisées mais en tout cas il y a
quelques jours, c'était encore le cas.
Euh et Ludovic Schaker dont le nom a été
dévoilé par le monde par les enquêtes
donc de de mes confrères et consœurs
notamment Arian Chemin et François Krug
Siton François euh est également un
élément extrêmement important donc du
dispositif à l'Élysée autour d'Alexandre
Benala dont on a beaucoup moins parlé.
Alors peut-être parce qu'il s'appelle
pas Benala mais qui a son importance.
Or, qu'est-ce que je montre dans tout un
chapitre euh ironiquement peut-être un
peu intitulé l'espion du président ?
Donc euh je parle de de tout le
parcours, j'ai fait toute une enquête
sur euh Ludovic Schaker euh et euh
euh et qu'est-ce que j'ai démontré ?
C'est que Pascal Perez connaissait
Ludovic Shaker depuis leurs origines
nimoises. Alors Lud Shaker, il
originaire d'un petit village des
Sévenes dans l'Avron. Bon, à une
centaine de kilomètres de Nî, c'est pas
tout près, mais euh avait des contacts
notamment via son oncle Claude Hter qui
est une personnalité du monde du rugby
euh avait des contacts avec donc
différents réseaux de du sud-est de la
France et notamment avec Pascal Perez.
Pourquoi c'est important ? Pascal Perez,
elle connaît Thierry Mariani, elle
connaît Nicolas Sarkozi, elle a partagé
plusieurs voyages avec tous ces gens-là
pendant le quinquena SarkoZi officiel,
voyage officiel, elle fait des affaires
avec l'Azerbaïdjan. Elle s'occupe des
routes de la soie, elle a un bureau pour
les Chinois à Genève également. Donc
c'est quelqu'un de très connecté. Euh,
elle va régulièrement à Londres euh
également et donc c'est elle qui a donné
euh les clés entre guillemets euh 2
jours après l'article du monde, enfin
même le peut-être 24 heures même si son
si on est précis, euh Alexandre Benala
et sa femme ou future femme euh pour le
déménagement et peut-être éventuellement
dans le coffre. Ça, il y a aucun élément
qui pour l'instant le le prouve. Il y a
des faisceaux concordants et mais pour
l'instant, il y a aucun élément qui le
prouve. Euh mais euh il y a un
témoignage de Choakrique que il a vu un
coffre ouvert dans l'appartement de
l'avenue Foche et donc c'est
l'appartement loué par Pascal Perez à
Paris. Et donc euh ça c'est extrêmement
important parce queen fait
je te coupe
ouais
euh on va demander d'acheter le livre
parce que là là ça fait quand même
2h30
là. Donc on va prendre quelques
questions et
je finis juste sur Pascal Perez. Euh
donc c'est quelqu'un de de de sûrement
très très respectable mais ce que je là
c'était pour rebondir sur Squarini la
Sarcosie. Et qu'est-ce que j'ai
découvert ces dernières semaines ? parce
que j'ai eu d'autres sources, d'autres
gens. J'ai rencontré d'autres gens. Euh
qui avait lancé la rumeur sur Bernard
Scorcini ?
Emmanuel Macron lui-même lors d'une
réunion de crise qui a eu lieu le
vendredi 2 jours après moins de 48
heures après l'article du monde. Donc
voilà, voilà comment les rumeurs ou le
cadrage ou le complot peut être balancé
par certains acteurs y compris au plus
haut niveau de l'État qui peuvent
parfois le faire de bonne fois mais
peuvent le faire parfois aussi par
intérêt parce qu'ils ont intérêt à ne
pas montrer toute la réalité du dossier.
Et je finirai sur Pascal Perez parce que
les gens verront de toute façon
effectivement si ça les intéresse. Et
puis il y a pas que il y a pas a pas y a
pas a pas il y a pas que Pascal Perz. Et
Pascal Perez, bon je vais pas trop en
parler parce que j'ai pas envie d'avoir
enfin je vais pas parler mais Pascal
Perez, il y a un élément, il y a une
consœur. Donc je cite mes confrères et
consœurs donc Caroline Michel chef
enquête de l'OPS qui a fait qui a fait
une enquête qui est plutôt fouillée et
bon qui est passé dans le nouvel
observateur enfin dans l'OPS euh une
enquête de quatre pages sur Pascal Perez
qu'elle présente comme l'ami d'Agistan
Benala. ce qui est vrai. Euh, elle parle
assez peu de Ludovic Shaker dans cette
enquête. Bon, elle fait elle elle j'en
parlais dans de mon côté, donc elle elle
a ses priorités de de de d'enquête, mais
elle dévoile un truc euh dont on avait
déjà une partie d'éléments mais que
personne avait pris en compte. C'est
quoi le 14 juillet 2018 donc on aé enfin
c'est même avant le 14 juillet, enfin
dans ces esparages là, je suis plus que
le 14 juillet c'est le 14 juillet, mais
je sais plus si exactement
ton temps, il demande encore 2 heures de
plus.
Ouais. Euh et bien qu'est-ce qui se
passe en donc c'est 3 jours 2 jours
avant la Fer Benala et qui euh qui est à
l'Élysée qui est à l'Élysée à ce
moment-là ? Il y a Alexandre Banala avec
Biofarina et euh
qui
est avec Pascal Perez.
OK. qui présente enfin qui présente non
je pense qu'il se connaissait mais en
tout cas Pascal Perez rencontre à ce
moment-là le couple Macron et pourquoi
parce que Pascal Perez fait rencontrer
au couple Macron Tom Cruise
voilà ça avait un tout petit peu fuité à
l'époque la visite de Tom Cruise à
l'Élysée mais comme ensuite il y avait
la Coupe du monde et la Ferbala c'était
à l'Élysée selon en tout cas les
informations de l'autre
c'est pas Bercy
non Tom Cruise Bercy c'est Sarkozi.
Ah oui, exact.
Mais Tom Cruise Macron, c'est à l'Élysée
élu.
Alors
grand grand acteur américain. Enfin bon
mais scientologue revendiqué.
Bon bah sous Sarkozi ça avait fait du
bruit Tom Cruise chez Bercy à Ber ça
avait fait du bruit. Il y avait des gens
qui avaient critiqué. Il y avait les
forces politiques d'opposants qui
avaient dit c'est inacceptable, c'est
dangereux, dérive sectair en plus
d'ailleurs, il y a une actualité,
il y a il y a une actualité suppression
de la la mission d'information
sur les sectes, la question du siège de
la scientologie qui doit débarquer où ?
Près du Stade de France à Saint-Nis. Bon
euh et donc euh Pascal Perez rencontre
enfin rencontre le couple présidentiel,
on est 3 jours avant la faire Benala et
euh
faire rencontrer au couple présidentiel
Tom Cruise. Et comme par hasard, c'est
la même Pascal Perez qui donne son
appartement à Benala une fois que le
scandale est sorti autour la place du
contreescarpe. Alors qu'à l'époque
l'Élysée continuait à nous dire "Mais
nous sommes en train de couper les
ponts" ou même si Macron dans ses
déclaration
sur comment dire ses déclarations à la
maison de l'Amérique latine disait tout
le grand bien qui pensait d'Alexandre
Benalaal fait quasiment applaudir lui a
rendu hommage il était là depuis le
début et puis ensuite on sait très bien
ça a été documenté je l'écris d'ailleurs
que les contacts ont continué et ont
continué et ont continué et ont continué
bon voilà bon voilà après je pourrais
parler plein de choses. Je pourrais
parler du nucléaire, je pourrais parler
du gaz, je pourrais parler de Kretinski,
je pourrais parler je pourrais je
pourrais parler d'ADP. J'ai fait un
article dans le monde diplomatique qui
en parle de ces réseaux là. Voilà, j'ai
par de tout ça.
On va piocher ADP. Euh,
tu veux revenir
s'il y a une question mais sinon
sûr qu'il y a des questions sur ADP. Il
y a des questions sur ADP, sur le
nucléaire, sur la 5G.
Sur la 5G. Tiens, alors sur la 5G, c'est
pas que je veux pas parler de la DP,
mais j'ai j'ai déjà j'ai déjà écrit des
choses, donc je je renvoie enfin
il y en a qui demandent un lien promo
pour acheter ton livre.
Euh bah ça je sais pas, il pouvoir Bon
euh
le le
euh Oui, la 5G. La 5G. Alors ça c'est
important la 5G. Euh
bon alors ça c'est pas c'est c'est pas
dans l'enquête que j'ai faite, c'est
parce que c'est enfin si il y a il y a
un élément qui qui apparaît dans
l'enquête. Euh il y a un paragraphe euh
où je parle des grands patrons de
presse, enfin des grands patrons de
presse, des des oligarques propriétaires
de médias euh qui euh euh qui donc ont
des activités dans les télécom. Bon et
donc qu'est-ce que j'évoque dans le
livre ? J'évoque Patrick Drahi. Euh
bon, j'en Patrick Dra effectivement qui
a soutenu Macron mais il y a longtemps
mais pendant la présidentielle, il y a
des éléments mais ça je l'ai déjà
expliqué ailleurs qui montrent qu'il
était plus forcément en soutien
d'Emmanuel Macron pendant la
présidentielle mais qu'il était plutôt
pour Emmanuel Vals. Bon euh tout ça
c'est dans la nuance mais c'est quand
même important. Et euh Patrick Dra a été
euh s'est retrouvé et son groupe Altis
SFR s'est retrouvé en grande difficulté
euh ces derniers mois euh parce que euh
il voulait imposer et d'ailleurs il a je
sais pas où son'en est mais il avait
commencé à vouloir en tout cas équiper
son futur réseau 5G avec des matériaux
chinois de Huawei et donc
qui représente peut-être une faille
qui représente peut-être une faille et
donc notamment de sécurité et de
souveraineté. Et euh Emmanuel Macron
pour le coup euh euh a voulu avoir un
ajada très ferme vis-à-vis de la 5G.
C'est-à-dire que il a décidé euh
de euh de mettre des bâtons dans les
roues à tous les acteurs économiques qui
voudront utiliser euh de euh la 5G
chinoise. En sachant qu'il y a euh je
suis pas spécialiste du secteur, mais un
déficit de de enfin aux États-Unis comme
en Europe, il y a peu de fournisseurs
pour ces technologies-là. Mais
potentiellement, il peut y en avoir. Euh
mais surtout Drahi comme d'autres
acteurs des télécomel
euh ont intérêt à baisser les coûts
parce que leur modèle est fait sur un
modèle de dumping de coût enfin au
niveau social mais également au niveau
de leur coût de structure. Et donc ils
sont très intéressés d'équiper leur
futur réseau 5G de matériel chinois. Bon
et bien l'Élysée euh le ministre de
l'économie Bruno Lumaire à plusieurs
reprises euh se sont euh ont très
clairement dit "Non, ça sera pas de la
5G chinoise."
Et il y a eu il y a eu là pour le coup
blocage de l'État fort et euh les
services
et qui voilà et qui allait à l'encontre
là pour le coup des intérêts de Patrick
Drahi.
Bon totalement.
et ce qui peut expliquer d'ailleurs une
distanciation qui est je pense plus
ancienne à l'égard d'Emmanuel Macron.
Là, c'est pour expliquer alors c'est un
contreexemple parfait sauf que une
interrogation que j'ai est-ce que c'est
une stratégie totale vis-à-vis de la
Chine sur le plan commercial stratégique
et de souveraineté ou est-ce qu'il y a
d'autres secteurs où qui apparaîtront
comme moins stratégique dans la tête
d'Emmanuel Macron ? Et là, on en revient
à une chose que j'ai pas évoqué, c'est
que sur tous ces dossiers industriels
là, il a stratégiqu bien évidemment, il
y a des il y a des il y a des il y a des
boîtes d'intelligence économique, il y a
il y a les services, il y a bon qui sont
encore opérants quand même dans le
secteur.
Euh je suis gentil. Euh
tu es très gentil.
Oui, ben
je peux pas me faire des des ennemis
partout. Bon non, donc oui, je suis très
gentil. notamment le bilan du
contreespionnage économique est est une
catastrophe parce que on a tout mis pour
des raisons politiques et donc tout le
tout l'objectif a été mis sur le
contterrorisme et donc à force de faire
du contreerrorisme déjà le
contreespionnage ne fait plus de
contreespionnage politique et
idéologique enfin et puis vis-à-vis pas
idéologique je mais je veux dire
politique au sens international du terme
mais en plus ne fait plus de de ou très
peu de contreespionnage économique et de
et de de de veille de d'intelligence
économique. Donc il y a il y a il y a
une vraie il y a une vraie
externalisation et de l'intelligence
économique en France, ce qu'on appelle
l'intelligence économique en France à
des boîtes privé et ça pose question
quant à justement à la à la à la la non
omniscience de l'État ou en tout cas à
la à la dépendance de l'État vis-à-vis
de sources privées sur ces domainesl.
Mais je reviens à un élément important
euh qui est le suivant, c'est que sur la
5G vraisemblablement Macron se paye les
opérateurs de téléphone en direct. euh
euh qui sont pourtant propriétaires de
médias. Donc bon, ça peut avoir un coup.
Ça c'est ce que j'expliquais. J'ai été
reçu par un petit cercle de réflexion au
Sénat après la sortie du du livre et
donc devant moi, il y avait
principalement des gens de la Macronie.
Et donc euh comme pour revenir à l'idée,
moi je suis simplement journaliste, je
suis de gauche. Donc la politique du
gouvernement n'est pas forcément la
mienne. Mais sur d'autres éléments, je
trouve qu' il y a des éléments
intéressants, mais sur d'autres non.
Mais euh mes enquêtes sont des enquêtes
factuelles. Et donc euh euh ce qui est
difficile, c'est qu'on enquête avec des
faits aujourd'hui la la on est
disqualifié politiquement. Ah, vous êtes
opposant en régime. C'est ce qu'on
rétorque. C'est ce que par exemple sur
le le seul plateau que j'ai fait sur
France Interre, c'était le soir à 23h30
et je me suis retrouvé face à Romain
Goupil et Romain Goupil me traitait
comme l'opposant numéro 1. Bon, c'est
assez facile de Romain Goupil, il me
tutoyait comme si j'ai un garçon gentil,
je l'ai laissé me tutoyer. Mais euh ça
c'est pour la difficulté de continuer à
faire du journalisme quand il y a une
sorte d'unanimisme politique et
conformisme, y compris dans toutes les
structures de pouvoir. Bref, je reviens
au Sénat l'anecdote sur le Sénat et donc
au Sénat, j'étais donc plutôt avec des
gens qui étaient très très bienveillants
à l'égard du pouvoir actuel. On va dire
ça comme ça. Et en plus
et toi tu débarques, tu casses
l'ambiance.
Non mais parce qu'on m'avait invité
quand même, les organisateurs m'avaient
invité.
Après, tu viens plus aux soirées
et voilà. Et les organisateurs m'avaient
invité dans un salon du Sénat pour
parler rapidement parce que j'avais un
autre un autre une autre conférence que
je donnais. dans bon je je remplaçais
quelqu'un au pied levé et euh et là j'ai
j'avais en face de moi donc des gens qui
avaient pas lu mon livre donc ils se
sont dit mince euh il est complotiste et
mince c'est le
maronnier de presse sur les réseaux
d'ailleurs vous a vous avez peut-être
remarqué il y a quand même beaucoup
moins de maronniers de presse sur les
réseaux depuis que Macron est arrivé au
pouvoir. Bon, petite remarque au
passage, mais
le le le le gens pensent enfin quand qui
connaissent pas mon travail et il y en a
plein qui connaissent pas mon travail
pensent que c'était donc un maronnier de
presse. Et c'est vrai que le bouquin a
été de la part de l'éditeur aussi un peu
vendu comme ça euh parce que ça ça
permettait à ce que ça soit moins
frontal d'une certaine manière. Euh
voilà. Euh e bien euh à ces gens-là,
j'ai expliqué ben justement euh
vous-même vous devriez vous informer sur
la réalité des rapports de force dans
les réseaux et notamment dans ces
réseaux économiques, parce que vous
comprendriez peut-être plus de choses
sur ce qui est en train de se passer, y
compris entre votre majorité ou le
président de la République et certains
grandes forces économiques actuellement
euh en France et notamment sur le
dossier des télécom. Ça pourrait
peut-être vous intéresser euh notamment
quand ils sont propriétaires des médias.
Là, je n'ai pas d'éléments factuels
réellement pour expliquer que mais je
revenais à l'histoire de BIG et de
Nicolas Sarkozy en 2012.
Qu'est-ce que j'ai expliqué tout à
l'heure ? C'est que Big qui était
pourtant témoin de mariage de Sarkozy ou
vice versa parin de ses enfants, je sais
plus,
ses intérêts industriels étaient
supérieurs à son amitié historique et
même à son idéologie entre guillemets.
De toute façon, tous ces gens-là pensent
à peu à peu près globalement la même
chose du point de vis-à-vis de la
globalisation financière. Mais enfin
quoi que il y en a qui sont plus
industrieux ou industriels que le
financier, mais BIG en l'occurrence est
plus industriel et donc et d'ailleurs il
souhaite plutôt la paix sociale Big
hein. Donc bon c'est l'ancien patronat
hein, il veut pas bon et ben Buig avec
Nicolas Sarkozy a pourtant lâché Nicolas
Sarkozy pendant son quinquena et et donc
et ça a eu des conséquences pour Nicolas
Sarkozy entre 2010 et 2012. Bon ça c'est
documenté. J'en ai même fait une enquête
à l'époque sur les coulisses de la
campagne de Nicolas Sarkozi. Là, je
parle pas de minimal, mais j'avais fait
une enquête et où justement des membres
du groupe Fourtou euh que j'ai cité tout
à l'heure m'avaient expliqué très
clairement que il s'était euh constitué
en en micro lobbing pour sauver le
soldat SarkoZi vis-à-vis vis-à-vis euh
des forces économiques. Euh là, j'ai
cité Boing mais il y avait bien
évidemment d'autres d'autres
personnages. Par exemple, autre élément
extrêmement extrêmement je le raconte
extrêmement important à comprendre,
Serge Dassau, le vieux- père Serge d'Ass
qui est qui est mort il y a pas
longtemps, je sais plus l'année
dernière.
Oui. Bon, Serge D'Asso,
il était très content sous le quinquena
François Hollande. C'est le seul
quinquena où il a réussi à vendre des
rafales et pas n'importe quel pays, à
l'Égypte, Qatar, à l'Inde et à l'Égypte
avec de l'argent saoudien
principalement, hein, comme les BPC.
Bon, ça a quand même des implications
sur la diplomatie française. Bon et bien
euh euh BPC, ils vont pas comprendre, il
faut que tu délayes.
Alors BPC, c'est les bâtiments euh
moi-même j'arrive pas à l'expliquer mais
les BPC c'est c'était des des beaux
bâtiments de porte hélicoptère. Oui. en
partie et euh qui avait été Attends, les
BP, attends attends attends, tu racontes
pas un peu n'importe quoi sur les portes
hélicoptères ? Comment ça s'est passé la
vente des portes hélicoptères à l'Égypte
? Parce qu'ils étaient destinés à la
Russie au départ les portes
hélicoptères.
Oui, mais sauf que François Hollande a
eu la décision politique de pas les
vendre finalement à la Russie. il étai
quasiment livrés d'ailleurs à tel point
que dans le programme il y a il y a des
bris glaces.
Bon, ça c'est une petite histoire mais
qui qui a son importance.
C'est passé c'est passé par l'Égypte.
Bah ça a été acheté par les Égyptiens
et c'était Tu es sûr que c'était de
l'argent saoudien derrière ?
J'ai pas les preuves là pour j'ai pas
fait d'enquête. Il
avait pas une caution, il y avait pas
une caution d'une banque française
là-dedans.
Ah ça je sais pas. Mais ce que je veux
te dire, ce que je veux dire par là,
c'est que euh
ça là pour le coup, tu as une
information que j'ai pas. Mais euh en
tout cas, ce qui est sûr, c'est que euh
Serge Dassau, je reviens à Sergeau, euh
était très content de François Hollande
et de Jean-Ive Ludrian. D'ailleurs, il
l'a dit lors d'une interview en
20167 c il était interviewé par le
Figaro et il était très très content de
de François Hollande et Jean-Vilien. Il
a dit "C'est le meilleur ministre de la
défense qu'on a eu et c'est le meilleur
président qu'on a eu et compagnie."
Il il était pas il était pas très
content de voir arriver Macron au
départin. Et d'ailleurs, bon, il est
père à son âme et comme tu dis, il est
il est il est mort. Mais euh euh voilà,
le groupe d'assaut et Macron,
ça a été compliqué au début. Et
d'ailleurs, c'est c'est Macron lui-même
qui est très transparent parfois qui l'a
dit lors lors d'une interview qu'il a
donné au point. Et dans cette interview
au point, on était en août 2017. Il dit
dans l'interview que il en a marre des
propriétaires enfin des industriels de
l'armement propriétaire de presse. Il
visait principalement euh Serge d'Assu
et qui instrumentalisait, pensa-t-il,
euh le Figaro au moment de du de
l'épisode d'Ovilier qui partait
enfin que que Macron a fait partir. Et
voilà. Et donc encore une fois là, on
est euh on est dans dans des secteurs où
euh les intérêts industriels prime et où
euh où les et les et voilà et où ça peut
avoir des incidences sur la politique
bien évidemment, mais où il y a du
rapport de force. Voilà,
je te coupe même si la communauté
réclame 2 heures de plus et on les
remercie euh bah
une prochaine fois
euh oui, je peux acheter du W40, ils
sont en train de se [__] de moi parce
que j'ai une chaise qui grince donc euh
donc une prochaine fois, ce sera avec
grand plaisir. Par contre, tu sais, on a
une tradition euh ici, c'est demander
trois bouquins à lire, à conseiller à la
communauté et et un conseil pour les
jeunes générations.
Oh [__] !
Euh
alors un alors un un une question sur
Brigitte.
Question sur Brigit.
Question sur Brigitte.
C'est quoi la question sur Brigitte ?
Alors dans quel réseau d'influence
Brigitte euh fait partie Brigitte M.
Quel réseau d'influence ?
Euh ne soyons pas complotistes. Euh
Brigitte Macron,
c'est qui porte la culotte à la maison
ou pas ? Ah
bah j'irai pas sur ce terrainlà. Euh,
elle a été très importante dans la
sensation dans l'ascension d'Emanuel
Macron. Euh, dans la première enquête,
je l'avais pas vu autant. C'est-à-dire
que bah là, pour le coup, euh bah les
sources étaient moins prolix, elles
étaient plus prudentes.
Prolix, ça veut dire parler beaucoup.
Ouais. Euh et oui, désolé. Parfois je
fais des fautes de français, parfois je
m'exprime mal et parfois le français est
très agréable à l'écoute.
Donc sur le premier livre et la première
enquête, j'avais j'avais parlé de
Brigitte Macron, parcours à mien avec
Macron et compagnie. Mais ce que ce dont
je me suis aperçu à travers la deuxième
enquête, c'est qu'elle avait eu une
importance importante dans le résutage
de Macron, dans l'accession au pouvoir
de Macron mais depuis 10 ans notamment.
Alors ça ça a déjà été raconté mais je
le raconte. c'est euh le fait que elle
ait même utilisé euh le l'enseignement
qu'elle faisait comme profissement
privé du 16e arrondissement qui
s'appelle Franklin. Euh établissement
privé où il y a toutes les chartes
blondes de d'une bonne partie de la
grande bourgeoisie économique et du
grand patronat français. Euh enfant de
Baladure qui était là-bas, euh
la mère de Bruno Lemire a enseigné à
Franklin. Euh euh bon bref, on est
vraiment dans les hautes sphères de la
bourgeoisie telles ont pu être décrites
par les les sociologues pinçon Charlot.
Et euh effectivement euh oui, par
exemple, Brigitte Macron a permis à à
Emmanuel Macron de rencontrer Bernard
Arnaud. Euh ça c'est vrai. Euh et c'est
vrai que euh elle a elle a elle a eu euh
plusieurs enfants euh euh de Bernard de
son 2e mariage euh dans dans sa classe.
Ça c'est vrai aussi. et quelqu'un qui me
le dit ouvertement parce que il y a eu
beaucoup de fantasmes mais qui m'a
permis de vérifier, il m'a dit que je
pouvais le dire ouvertement alors que
dans le livre c'est une citation
rapportée.
Euh oui, parce que ça ça a été un petit
reproche qu'on m'a fait dans le livre,
c'est qu'il y avait pas suffisamment de
citation sourcé
non au fait, mais c'est parce que j'ai
pris le parti de de protéger le maximum
mes sources
et que j'étais sûr de beaucoup de enfin
recouper quatre fois des informations,
je peux les délivrer et les assumer euh
sans passer par des sources euh des
citations, je veux dire. Euh mais donc
c'est euh l'ancien
euh enfin toujours adjoint au maire de
Inalgo, euh ancien euh salarié du groupe
LVMH, Christophe Gérard qui m'a qui m'a
expliqué qu'effectivement dès juin 2012,
il avait eu un coup de téléphone donc de
son ancien patron Bernard Arnaud et
qu'il Bernard Arnaud lui avait dit en
pleine polémique sur les 75 % la taxe
des 75 % euh sur les grands patrimoines
et grandes fortunes enfin sur la pose
sur le revenu et pas ISF désolé Euh et
donc Girard m'avait rapporté la
conversation, une partie de la
conversation qu'il a eu avec Bernard
Arnaud qui lui avait dit les mots
suivants. Il est très bien ce jeune
homme en parlant d'Emmanuel Macron. Il
faut il faut le soutenir, il faut
l'aider. Mais donc ça prouve une chose,
c'est que Bernard Arnaud connaissait
très bien Emmanuel Macron dès 2012 et
même vraisemblablement même précédemment
et que bien évidemment là ça met le on
met le doigt sur quelque chose
qu'Emmanuel Macron a a su utiliser
extrêmement manière extrêmement
pertinente, c'est que
euh en 20123, alors qu'h était quand
même proche de pas mal de grands
patrons, et bien il a réussi à à être le
bureau des pleurs d'une partie du
capitalisme français et donc là il est
très gentil avec eux d'ailleurs et c'est
pour ça qu'il y a eu une sorte de de
bruit du côté des des oligarques et
surtout du milieu économique qui à ce
moment-là a survalorisé Macron dans les
dîners en ville et autres. C'était en
tout cas sur cette périodeel là 2012-24.
Voilà.
Bon alors pendant que tu réfléchis à tes
trois bouquins, je te lis juste un petit
commentaire qui reflète beaucoup de
commentaires sur le channel. On ferait
mieux de faire 2 heures de plus
maintenant. On risque de plus jamais le
revoir.
Non non, j'ai j'ai alors j'ai j'ai juste
pour faire un petit point personnel,
j'ai j'ai retrouvé des quelques
collaborations en pige. J'ai quand même
travaillé 9 ans en pige. Donc c'est
j'avais pas prévu de partir de Marianne
et de me retrouver de nouveau en pige.
Mais euh comme me l'a dit une conœur,
tu es trop marqué maintenant. Bon alors
l'année prochaine tu veux du boulot.
H
l'année prochaine tu veux du boulot. Euh
non mais j'ai là ça va, j'ai suivant de
pige pour OK. Combien tu prends
de de de
de net
pour pour un job ?
Pour un job.
Ah ça euh je je dirais pas c'est pas
c'est pas
non non non. Si nous si nous on veut
t'engager à demeure.
Ah à demeure. Je sais pas. Je gagnais
euh je gagnais comme grand reporter,
c'était mon titre. C'est une grille de
salaire à Marianne, je gagnais 3200
nets. Voilà.
Ouais. Tu es cher.
Bon, on y réfléchira. Les trois
bouquins.
Euh les trois bouquins. Alors
à 3000 3000 tu acceptes
[Musique]
euh les trois bouquins euh un tout petit
bouquin, un tout petit livre euh
mais qui une qui une claque
euh
tout petit livre mais qui une claque aux
éditions du sonneur, petite maison
d'édition.
C'est une autoanalyse, une
autobiographie de Jack London euh qu'il
a fait qu'il a écrite 1 an et demi, 2
ans avant son suicide euh
qui s'appelle Ce que la vie signifie
pour moi.
Ça raconte comment Jack London, donc
écrivain, grand écrivain américain, mais
qui était également prof d'université et
était d'extraction populaire, fils
d'ouvrier. qui raconte aussi l'Amérique
ouvrière du 19e siècle et du début du
20e siècle et il raconte comment il est
monté par ascension sociale, échelon
après échelon, au sein même de
l'establishment intellectuel
universitaire américain. Et en fait, il
explique comment il en est sorti
notamment jusqu'à sa malheureuse fin de
vie
par des goût. par des goûts.
Oui, principalement et par
déconstruction et par distanciation
vis-à-vis des valeurs qu'il avait au
départ partagé. Et c'est très
intéressant notamment par rapport aux
questions qu'on peut se poser sur ce
qu'on appelle entre guillemets le
système en général.
Euh c'est est-ce que on on collabore
pour des raisons professionnelles à à
tel type d'institution ou est-ce qu'on
est à l'extérieur et queon essaie pas de
changer les choses de l'intérieur ? et
ça pose beaucoup de questions de ça sur
ça. Et par ailleurs, c'est un texte qui
est très court, ça fait à peine 60
pages, qui est très ciselé, qui est très
fort. Et donc ça c'est Jack London ce
que ce que la vie signifie pour moi. Il
y a un petit livre, enfin un plus gros
livre mais euh alors c'est un ami donc
c'est du copinage mais
mais c'est par rapport aux histoires de
presse et de propriété des médias.
C'est un ancien journaliste de la
tribune et et de Libération qui
s'appelle Jean Sterne
qui a été donc rédacteur en chef adjoint
à la tribune et qui a été grand reporter
à Libération qui a été aussi qui a fait
l'éditing pendant longtemps de
Libération. L'éditing c'est les titres,
c'est la mise en page. Jean Stern a fait
un livre assez choc entre guillemets
mais peu diffusé euh enfin qui s'est
vendu mais peu diffusé en 20101.
aux éditions de la Fabrique euh petit
éditeur dire de gauche de gauche. Euh ça
s'appelle tout simplement patron de
presse nationale de points tous mauvais.
Euh le titre dit tout et Jean dans le
livre revient à la fois sur ce que
j'expliquais tout à l'heure, sur la
fragilité industrielle de la presse, sur
la question des syndicats et y compris
de la CGT d'une certaine manière,
syndicat du livre et puis surtout sur la
manière dont des grandes rédactions
comme Libération Le Monde s'étaient
laissé entraîner dans le rachat de leur
leurs propres journaux. C'est très
intéressant et surtout il parle d'une
chose qui a été un peu en partie révélée
par Maxime Rini au médiia sur la
défiscalisation
utilisé enfin que DRI utilisait
notamment sa propriété de presse par des
holdings par des systèmes de facturation
si j'ai bien compris l'enquête en fait
utilisait ces journaux y compris pour
faire de la diffalisation à travers des
des des montages de de holding en fait
genre l'avait démontré à travers ce
petit livre et il étudie le le montage
financier de différents groupes de
presse certes de l'époque. Donc ça le
bouquin a à 6 7 ans donc il fait il est
actualisé mais il est il est il est très
intéressant à il est très intéressant à
lire. Et un troisème livre euh
euh
ça serait un un un polar que j'ai pas
fini de lire parce que je je travaille
trop et donc je lis pas assez. En tout
cas, je je je je je je lis je lis pas
assez en tout cas de bouquin. C'est un
polar mais dont j'ai plus dont j'ai plus
le nom de pourtant c'est un grand auteur
de polar américain. Euh mais c'est un
livre sur la police new yorkaaise et
la collusion de la police new yorkaaise
Ripu et Gang et qui s'appelle
manipulation au pluriel si je me suis si
je me trompe pas dans le titre. Ça c'est
dans la traduction la traduction
française. Voilà. Tu as oublié un truc ?
Ah, le conseil
pour les jeunes générations.
Pour les jeunes générations,
un truc impérissable qui fait un peu cuc
cucul la praline.
Mais mais c'est important, ça fait vieux
con
et et et de temps en temps c'est bien de
faire le vieux con. Je suis bientôt
enfin je suis déjà un vieux con, j'ai 38
ans. Donc
euh
il vient de prendre une claque à ma
gauche.
Euh euh
qu'est-ce que je peux dire ? Croyez en
vous. Et puis ça c'est complètement con.
Mais euh
tu es pour contre la grève ? Tu es pour
contre la grève ?
Bien sûr, je suis pour la grève. Bien
sûr, bien sûr, je suis pour la grève.
Euh bien sûr que
bien sûr c'est un projet de régression
sociale auquel on assiste qui est ancien
d'ailleurs
qui est ancien mais les démocraties
notamment les plus vieilles comme la
celle qu'on peut connaître en France euh
je crois que la entre la question
climatique l'écologie et la question de
l'ultrafinanciarisation du monde
On a il faut jamais oublier que les
tensions politiques auxquelles on
assiste sont aussi liées à la gestion de
la crise financière de 2008 déjà à la à
la la survenue de cette crise financière
systémique comme on a dit d'une manière
assez technicienne et par euphémisme
mais une crise financière où les gens
qui ont été responsables n'ont jamais
payé ou très peu
où des peuples entiers ont été
précarisés, la Grèce notamment et on a
assisté à des ajustements structurels
néolibéraux dans plein de pays et et
cette situation là qui est maintenant
qu'on paye depuis 10 ans, voilà, tous
les sous-brosseaux qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui est issu notamment de ces de
cette crise financière et systémique et
on ne peut pas demander au peuple de
renflouer des établissements bancaires.
qui sont fous, c'est la finance folle.
hors la loi enfin alors qu'elle agit
souvent dans la loi mais en tout cas
hors la loi morale et et en plus hors
les intérêts, y compris euh de la
bourgeoisie ou des CSP+ comme on dit qui
ont intérêt eux d'une certaine manière,
c'est pas moi qui le disait, c'est
Pierre Bourdieu, je je revoyais une
vidéo de lui de Pierre Carl euh qui
disait que la bourgeoisie a intérêt à
assurer la paix sociale. Donc aussi et
donc le le programme économique
d'Emmanuel Macron extrêmement dur.
D'ailleurs euh je l'avais euh un écrit
dans la première enquête, l'ambigue.
Alors c'était l'ambigu par rapport à
l'État, à la démocratie justement et je
savais très bien que c'était un
néolibéral, y compris dans la casse euh
de des protections sociales, de
l'assurance chômage parce que ça
Schroder l'a fait il y a 15 20 ans en
Allemagne. Tony Blair suite à Toucher en
Angleterre l'avait fait également. Et à
l'époque, il y a plein de gens dans la
macroni qui m'expliquaient "Mais non,
c'est le modèle Suédois. Euh vous allez
voir, c'est pas exactement non, c'est
pas Toucher." Bon, depuis le début du
quinquena euh ce qui est clair, c'est
que Emmanuel Macron est en frontal par
rapport au minimaateurs
appellent les corps intermédiaires tout
simplement les profs qui enseignent au
gosses des uns et des autres. Et donc
euh effectivement euh on est dans une
situation très très compliquée parce que
on en a pas peu parlé euh mais pour
revenir à la à la à la à la gouvernance
très autoritaire finalement d'Emmanuel
Macron en tout cas vertical comme on a
dit hein Jupiter c'est tous les termes
de journalisme politique qui a qui a pu
arriver dès dès 2017. Euh il a une
volonté du choc enfin une stratégie du
choc et donc euh
pas façon naomique. Bah si presque,
c'estàd que enfin pas façon au sens Oui.
En tout cas des au niveau euh euh
néolibéral du terme,
choc doctrine,
voilà. Mais surtout du choc pour tuer
euh toute opposition, notamment toute
opposition sociale. Et et donc c'est
très très important à à à prendre en
compte parce que les syndicats là
aujourd'hui jouent gros gros parce que
on n'est pas on n'est même pas dans
l'espèce de concertation. lui, il veut
sa victoire symbolique euh même
électorale parce queil sait très bien
que maintenant sa base électorale c'est
en partie les électeurs de Fillon qui de
toute manière voulait ce qu'il est en
train de faire.
en tout cas sur le plan économique,
j'entends et euh et par ailleurs
euh plus profondément euh il il ne
supporte pas en fait il ne prend pas en
compte ce qu'on appelé ce qu'on a appelé
durant de nombreuses années en France ce
qu'on appelle la question sociale.
C'estd que la démocratie sociale, il
sait pas ce que ça veut dire et donc il
est il est c'est d'où son rapport très
grande distanciation par rapport à la
population, y compris le fait qu'il ait
pas eu de carrière politique
traditionnelle hein, le cursus d'un
autre temps comme il l'appelait à
l'époque
[Musique]
ironiquement vis-à-vis de ses congénères
politiques et et donc non à un moment
donné il ne peut pas être que dans la
technocratie la plus abrupte pour
gouverner un pays et par ailleurs. Je
vais citer un interlocuteur que j'ai eu
pendant l'enquête qui est pourtant un
ancien ministre de Jacques Chirac
qui me disait la chose suivante dont on
a jamais parlé sur les plateaux de
télévision généralement
où ça me fait penser à Romain Goupil.
Euh ce ministre de Chirac me disait la
chose suivante : "On était en plein
mouvement des gilets jaunes et il disait
oui, il a la légitimité
constitutionnelle Macron mais il n'a
plus aujourd'hui la légitimité
politique."
Voilà. Et cette distinction est
extrêmement importante. Oui, il a la
légitimité juridique constitutionnelle
et comme on dit, on est dans un état de
droit. Donc il a les pouvoirs et les
pouvoirs euh qu'il a sont légitimes. Il
a été élu. Bon, mais euh aujourd'hui, il
n'a plus la base politique en réalité
pour faire son programme, dit-il. Et en
plus, on sait très bien qu'une bonne
partie de son élection est d à une
élection par défaut face à Marine Le Pen
et il n'attend que cela d'ailleurs de se
retrouver face à Marine Le Pen pour
jouer au chantage.
Voilà. Et alors, il y a quelqu'un dont
on n pas parlé qui le conseille sur ça.
Euh et puis il a eu aussi l'influence de
François Hollande d'une certaine manière
parce que Macron a été jusqu'au bout de
la stratégie de François Hollande en
2017 pour se faire réalir. François
Hollande voulait aussi utiliser
l'extrême droite comme Méran pendant un
temps pour essayer de de se faire
réélir. Et là en l'occurrence la
personne que je cite dans dans l'enquête
qui est étonnante alors qui est malade
en ce moment depuis plusieurs mois qui
un vieux monsieur mais l'ancien ministre
du budget de la mitarandie Michel
Charass et un très proche d'Emmanuel
Macron et n n'a pas cessé d'être en
contact avec Emmanuel Macron depuis le
début du de Septena j'allais dire du
quinquena Emmanuel Macron et Charaz bien
évidemment il distille
les trucs et astuces on va dire de
Miteran Sauf que la grande différence
entre Mitteran et Macron déjà là, on
peut parler de la culture ou de son
macavellisme ou de sa stature
historique. Après quoi qu'on pense de
Mitteran ? Mais Mitteran, il était élu à
partir d'une base sociale et d'une
gauche, d'un peuple de gauche comme on
dit, des syndicats, des associations,
des gens engagés dans la cité qu'on soit
de ce bord ou pas de ce bord, mais il
avait il représentait une partie de la
société française et quand il est devenu
président de la République, d'ailleurs
il a essayé aussi comme on dit la 5e
République de représenter tous les
Français. que ça marche ou ça que ça
marche ou ça marche pas ce système. Mais
c'est comme ça Emmanuel Macron là le
problème c'est que
c'est d'abord été une ambition personnel
avant d'être une ambition collective.
Marcand, vous venez de réussir votre
entretien d'embauche.
Ouais. La communauté Syerview vous
réclame pour 3 heures de plus, mais là
l'équipe technique va là, ça fait
bientôt 3h là
le plan large
et et en plus je dois faire un papier de
8 pages pour demain. Donc
et donc merci beaucoup, c'était fort
intéressant. Euh
on est parti dans tous les sens,
c'est catastrophe. Non, c'est c'est
J'ai pas fait Science Po Paris, j'ai
fait Science Po à Toulouse. J'ai fait
j'ai aucun esprit de synthèse. Trou on a
trouvé ça très bien. Euh merci. Le nom
des livres,
le nom des livres de mes livres. Euh de
mes livres bah France Télévision of the
Record histoire secrète d'une télé
publique sous influence. Mais ça c'est
quasiment plus disponible en commerce.
Enfin sur non, j'allais j'allais dire la
marque mais non. Voilà. et
et qui a un gros pavé de 500 pages sur
15 ans de télévision publique. Euh
l'ambigue, monsieur Macron, en version
poche parce que c'est celui qui est
actualisé où il y a toute la campagne,
où il y a six chapitres supplémentaires
où il y a euh une poste face et une
préface supplémentaire et euh le grand
manipulateur, les réseaux secrets de
Macron
sorti au printemps dernier mais qui est
encore en librairie
et dans tous les endroits où il y a mon
livre. Voilà.
Marcandevel, merci.
Merci à vous. Ah.
[Musique]